Guten Morgen Anna.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, wo steckt eigentlich Linos? Ist der irgendwie flüchtig.
Das können wir nicht sagen, wir können natürlich nicht ausschließen, dass Linus ein russischer Spion ist, aber wenn das so sein sollte, wären das ein herausragender Erfolg für die Russen.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer einhundertvierundachtzig,
vielleicht hat man's auch mal angewöhnt, hier ein Datum zu sagen, heute ist der zehnte Juni. Zwanzig sechzehn.
Und Linus ist nicht da und äh hat sich rausgeredet mit windigen,
mit findigen Argumenten. Nee, Quatsch, alles äh wie geplant,
schon gehört, äh, heute gibt's dafür einen anderen Gast, ich begrüße Anna Anna Biselli, hallo.
Aber du warst ja noch nicht bei uns.
Gut, dass es mal soweit ist, weil du bisher nun auch eine sehr.
Genau, ich arbeite bei Netzpolitik Org und schreibe da unter anderem die Live-Blogs zu dem NSL-Untersuchungsausschuss, wenn André nicht da ist oder verhindert ist oder wir uns das anderweitig aufteilen.
Ja unter anderem heißt aber, du bist, wie lange bist du jetzt schon dabei.
Ich bin jetzt seit bisschen mehr als zweieinhalb Jahren dabei, genau war da nur so zufällig mehr oder weniger, weil ich da ein Praktikum machen wollte und bin dann so ein bisschen,
hängengeblieben und dachte, Mensch, das ist ja eigentlich auch was, was ich mir die nächsten Jahre so vorstellen kann und bin dann so da reingerutscht, sage ich mal, so als.
Eigentlich Informatikerin und irgendwann habe ich gemerkt, dass das mit dem Journalismus und der Informatik sich ja eigentlich auch ganz gut verbinden lässt und habe gemerkt, das ist eigentlich gerade was, was man gut ausbauen kann.
Und dementsprechend dachte ich auch so gerade so technischere Themen, wo es gerade so um Überwachung geht, um mal so einzuschätzen, was geht eigentlich, was hat das eigentlich für eine Bedeutung, was ist so an Technik draußen gibt und was kann man damit machen? Ist eigentlich ganz praktisch, wenn man da so ein bisschen.
Von der Technikseite kommt und das auch ein bisschen anders sehen kann als jetzt von der politischen Seite oder nur der gesellschaftlichen Seite.
Ja, was denkst du, welchen Einfluss das hat auf deine Schreibe.
Auch das hängt hat bestimmt erstmal so den Einfluss, dass ich am Anfang natürlich erstmal so von dem ganzen journalistischen Schreiben oder so nicht so wirklich,
Plan hatte, dass erstmal irgendwie wirklich gelernt habe und aber auch immer wieder eine andere Perspektive dann hatte, irgendwie zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt irgendeinen Gesetzentwurf kommt, wo.
Auch geregelt wird, was Technik betrifft und dann irgendwie mal zu gucken, ist das überhaupt realistisch, was bedeutet das,
für die Technik, was wird da reguliert, um da einfach mal einen anderen Blick drauf zu werfen, als jetzt,
den gesellschaftlichen Diskurs, den man oft hat, um da auch Möglichkeiten anders bewerten zu können oder ich erkläre auch gern Leuten Sachen, weil ich einfach finde, dass es oft einfach ganz wichtig ist, auch die Technik zu verstehen, um eben,
politische Prozesse einschätzen zu können, das können oft die Politiker nicht mal selbst und deshalb verstehe ich das ein bisschen auch als Dienstleistung an die Leute, die die Entscheidung treffen und auch natürlich an die Leute, die sich informieren wollen
um das nochmal irgendwie zu beleuchten oder auch einfach mal einen Algorithmus zu erklären, zu gucken, was ist überhaupt möglich,
Wie ist es überhaupt möglich zum Beispiel auch Leute,
über Leute anzulegen, Leute zu überwachen, was ist realistisch, was nicht, was ist vielleicht.
Irgendwie nur Panik mache, was ist vielleicht realistisch und können wir uns noch gar nicht vorstellen und wie ist da so der Stand der Forschung und was läuft da vielleicht gerade ab.
Diese, diese technische Informiertheit in der in der politischen Diskussion, das ist ja auch das, was so den Chaos, Computerclub sehr, sehr lange und auch
bis heute eigentlich noch noch prägt so und in der Eigensicht der Szene, denke ich
sieht man das natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch als als Vorsprung, ist,
ist es wahrscheinlich auch auf jeden Fall ist ja klar, wenn man Dinge erstmal versteht, ist immer besser, als wenn man sie
nicht versteht, aber es gibt ja auch immer so ein bisschen den Vorwurf der Öffentlichkeit, dass so quasi dieser Nerd geprägte äh Blick
wiederum wichtige Aspekte rauslässt, ähm der eben auch noch zu bewerten wäre, beziehungsweise, dass man sich vielleicht auch zu sehr auf technische Details versteift und dann
oder ist das etwas, wo du dir zumindest mal Gedanken zugemacht hast, ob das so ist oder nicht.
Gerade so am Anfang habe ich das halt gemerkt, äh,
wusste ich halt weniger über diese ganzen politischen, sage ich mal, Prozesse oder wie sowas im Hintergrund abläuft, Bescheid und dann dachte ich halt er,
denken wir halt oft erstmal so wie wie warum machen die sowas? Sind die bescheuert so was denken die sich denn dabei
Und dann irgendwann kommt man halt irgendwie so ein bisschen in diese Prozesse rein und sieht halt auch diese ganzen politischen Abläufe, die Abläufe im Hintergrund, wie zum Beispiel Entscheidungen getroffen werden, wieder debattiert wird,
Dann merkt man halt, dass es auch noch ganz andere, sage ich mal, Zwänge gibt, außer jetzt einer technischen Realität, die Leute irgendwie dazu bringen, irgendwie Entscheidungen zu treffen,
und dass man natürlich auch so ein bisschen von aus seiner Blase rausgehen muss und sehen muss, dass die Leute natürlich irgendwie die Entscheidung treffen, nicht die Möglichkeiten haben, sich damit irgendwie vierundzwanzig sieben auseinanderzusetzen, weil die ja auch nur andere Sachen zu entscheiden haben und da eben.
So ein bisschen davon runterzukommen und eben auch so 'ne Brücke zu bauen und zu sagen so hier ich will Informationen geben, ich versuch euch das so zu erklären dass ihr das versteht dass es irgendwie einfach verständlich ist und da so ein bisschen.
Sich klar zu werden, dass man jetzt nicht nur mit technisch versierten und informierten Leuten zu tun hat, das war, glaube ich, ein Prozess, aber ich glaube, das ist mittlerweile auch ganz.
Ich habe schon das Gefühl, ja, ich glaube irgendwie zumindest, wenn man so eine Rückmeldung krie,
normalen Leserinnen und Leser, die eben vielleicht technisch interessiert sind oder politisch interessiert sind, aber eben auch gerade,
Leute aus der Politik, die dann glaube ich auch ganz froh sind, wenn man ihnen Sachen nochmal irgendwie aufbereitet. Also man ich habe zum Beispiel einmal die Rückmeldung gekriegt, so Mensch.
Wir müssen hier irgendwie dreißigtausend Themen am Tag bearbeiten und wir müssen uns irgendwie in der einen Minute, müssen wir uns mit Fischerei beschäf,
und einer anderen Minute mit irgendwas mit Technik und dann brauchen wir halt jemanden, der uns die Information quasi so
verdaubar irgendwie zusammenfasst und irgendwie nochmal darstellt, um dann eben eine Entscheidung treffen zu können und wenn das dann immer nur,
Leute machen, seien das jetzt irgendwie große Lobbyisten oder seien es irgendwie, sage ich mal, Überwachungsbefürworter, die da Ressourcen für haben, irgendwie Informationen schön zu machen, in Hochglanzpapierchen zu packen und,
Beispielsweise Abgeordneten jetzt irgendwie im Bundestag,
dann kriegen die erstmal nur die Information und ich glaube das ist einfach wichtig 'ne Gegenseite zu schaffen weil,
Ich sag mal wenn man jetzt nicht gerade bei den hoffnungslosen Fällen ankommt die überhaup,
sage ich mal, die Überwachungsfanatiker und Befürworter sind, sondern gerade so bei Leuten, die irgendwo in der Mit,
dann kann man da glaube ich noch ein bisschen was erreichen, wenn man den Leuten einfach die Information gut aufbereitet.
Hast du ja gesagt, du bist seit zweieinhalb Jahren dabei, da hast du im Prinzip noch so eine Zeit mitbekommen, wenn ich das noch so richtig äh eingeschätzt bekomme,
Bundespolitik orgt zwar schon sehr bekannt war, aber noch nicht noch nicht so diesen,
Über die Szene hinaus und über so eine, also journalistische und netzpolitische Szene hinaus, glaube ich, noch nicht so eine krasse Marke war. Dann kam ja jetzt
letzten Jahr haben wir ja auch ausführlich gecovert, die ganze Landesfahrradnummer und jetzt ste,
äh das kleine Blog im Prinzip so ein bisschen da, wie so das äh Sturmgeschützt der digitalisierungsgeprägten
Demokratie hat das euer,
Verhältnis zur Außenwelt oder das Verhältnis der Außenwelt zu euch irgendwie nennenswert geändert oder ist jetzt eigentlich alles nur wie vorher mit ein paar mehr Spenden und paar mehr Klicks.
Es haben sich viele Sachen intern geändert, wir sind viel größer geworden, ich sag mal am Anfang, als ich so angefangen hab, da saß ich mit, äh, Markus und Andre alleine in unserem Büro, das war irgendwie alles irgendwie klein und flauschig und mittlerweile sind wir irgendwie
fast zehn Leute, die jetzt nicht alle mit einer vollen Stelle da arbeiten, aber man merkt einfach, dass es so voller wird und dass wir uns irgen,
anders organisieren und Sachen einfach anders aufteilen müssen. Wir merken aber natürlich auch, dass,
viel mehr Leute lesen, Leute, die jetzt nicht so aus dieser Filterbubble kommen und sowieso schon irgendwie über ganz viel
Grundlagenwissen oder Interesse verfügen und das wird's dann irgendwie auch.
Zugängliche, sage ich mal, für die allgemeinen Bevölkerung machen mussten, für Leute, die jetzt nicht so viel Einstiegswissen haben, um die eben nicht abzuschrecken, weil sie eh schon daran interessiert waren, einfach auch nochmal so zu reflektieren, für wen machen wir das eigentlich,
was für eine Leser haben wir auf welchem Kenntnisstand sind die. Da hat sich schon einiges verändert, aber ich glaube das läuft auch gerade noch und wir sind da auch immer wieder,
oh, wenn Leute uns Rückmeldungen geben, was sie so sich wünschen, was sie vermissen und was sie gerne hätten.
Zehn Leute, das ist schon ganz ordentlich. Das kann man schon Redaktion nennen.
Kann man schon Redaktion nennen.
Dann sozusagen macht das dann die Arbeit äh einfacher oder ist es jetzt eher komplexer geworden dadurch, dass dass ihr euch mit noch mehr Themen und und noch mehr Inhalten äh,
beschäftigt oder sehr viel mehr mit interner Abstimmung zu tun hat. Kann ja Segen und Fluch zugleich sein.
Ich glaube ist es auch, also ich hatte irgendwann mal so die Beobachtung,
Mensch, wir werden jetzt immer mehr Leute, aber ich habe immer auch das Gefühl, es wird immer mehr Arbeit so und wir schaffen irgen,
Zum einen daran, dass einfach dieses Thema Netz,
viel öfter behandelt wird. Ich hab mir dann irgendwann mal angeschaut so rein statistisch war,
wird so im Bundestag zusätzpolitischen Themen behandelt und das wird immer mehr, das heißt irgendwie allein die Themen die relevant für uns sind werden einfach öfter besprochen und sage sei es jetzt irgendwie Überwachung, sei es Netzneutralität, sei es,
Ausbau und auf der anderen Seite müssen wir uns natürlich auch abstimmen und das natürlich auch ein Wachstu,
bei dem wir mit uns selbst irgendwie erstmal wachsen müssen und gucken, wie machen wir das eigentlich.
Markus hat mal in irgendeinem Interview gesagt auf die Frage nach Netzpolitik als solche, was sind das ist? Dass er eigentlich meint, dass,
was wir heute noch Netzpolitik bezeichnen, heißt eigentlich in Zukunft Politik. Das das ist sozusagen eigentlich sich.
So interpretiere ich das jetzt mal, löst aus diesen digitalen äh vernetzten Fangarmen und und sich daraus äh entwickelnden politischen Szene hin zu den eigentlichen Themen der nächsten Zeit,
wie gehst du mit so einer Sichtweise um.
Es gab ja auch mal so ein bisschen unseren Versuch, das zu definieren als Netzpolitik ist,
Das, wie das Internet die Politik beeinflusst und wie die Politik das Internet beeinflusst und gerade wenn wir uns überlegen,
dieses Internet gerade überall ist und überall drinsteckt, haben wir eben nicht mehr,
diese Trennschärfe, dass wir sagen können, das ist jetzt hat jetzt kein netzpolitischen,
Zusammenhang, wir müssen halt irgendwie gucken, was sind so wirklich die Kernthemen, die wir behandeln wollen und müssen und was sind halt Themen, die am Rande auch damit zu tun haben oder wo das einen Einfluss darauf hat, wo man auch manchmal vielleicht
den Einfluss unterschätzt und dann irgendwie erst später sieht, was das für eine Bedeutung haben kann, was das Internet eben überall ist. Wir können eben dieses,
Internet nicht mehr da rausnehmen. Wir können zum Beispiel auch aus der Bildungspolitik diese ganze Digitalschiene nicht mehr rausnehmen, wenn wir uns überlegen, es gibt sowas wie Medienkompetenzen, da liegt einiges brach, also ich glaube so dieses Internet, was die Gesellschaft durchtrinkt, heißt eben auch, dass das Internet die Politik massiv durchtrinkt.
So jetzt wollten wir heute mal einen Schwerpunkt machen.
Wir nennen das ja immer gerne Spezial. Ein Spezial. Wir machen ein Spezial und zwar äh feiern wir gerade ein schönes Jubiläum, äh hundert Jahre NSA Untersuchungsausschuss.
Nee, Quatsch, nicht hundert Jahre, aber die hundertste Sitzung.
Genau, die war letzte Woche am Donnerstag und.
Das war die hundertste Sitzung, wobei das vielleicht ein bisschen irreführend ist, wenn man das so hört, weil da wundert man sich vielleicht so, ja, es gab jetzt hundert Sitzungen, aber wieso,
nur so um die fünfzig Protokolle, habt ihr da die Hälfte irgendwie verschlafen? Die haben wir nicht und zwar
wird im Bundestag ein bisschen anders gezählt, nämlich die zählen jeweils die nicht öffentlichen Sitzungen und die öffentlichen Sitzungen einzeln, das heißt normalerweise so der reguläre
Donnerstages mit dem NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss in den Sitzungswochen ist eben so, dass ein Teil der Sitzung nicht öffentlich ist, das heißt, die Öffentlichkeit, die auch nicht besuchen darf und ein anderer Teil der Sitzung ist eben öffentlich,
das heißt, Menschen dürfen sich da reinsetzen und dem zuhören, wenn sie sich vorher angemeldet haben,
und dementsprechend können wir schon sagen, es gab so um die fünfzig Sitzungstage, aber eben nach der Bundestagszählung jetzt die hundertste Sitzung.
Das heißt, die Hälfte war öffentlich, die Hälfte war nicht öffentlich.
So grob, also das kann man jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig sagen, es kann auch mal sein, dass eine extra nicht öffentliche Sitzung irgendwie da war oder irgendwie vielleicht an einem Tag eine nicht öffentliche Sitzung nicht stattgefunden hat, aber das kann man so halb halb ungefähr aufteilen.
Ja, na gut, runde Zahlen sind auch nur dazu da, dass man Anlass hat, äh, eine Sondersendung zu machen,
Ähm genau und das wollten wir jetzt mal,
Ähm.
Du hast ja, vielleicht fangen wir damit auch mal äh an, hast ja auch schon angedeutet zusammen mit äh Andre, also ich glaube Andre hat damit angefangen, ne? War das so?
Genau, Andre hat angefangen, irgendwann war André dann ein halbes Jahr im Urlaub und dann habe ich das übernommen und momentan teilen wir uns das auf, je nachdem, was gerade am besten passt.
Wer gerade so kann. Das heißt, ihr seid dann äh oder einer von euch,
dann einfach vor Ort die ganze Zeit während der Sitzung, die er teilweise sehr lange dauert, ich weiß nicht wie viel Zeiteinsatz bedeutet das, acht Stunden länger.
Das ist auf jeden Fall meistens länger, das heißt die Sitzungen fangen in der Regel so um elf dreißig an, das ist so die normale Anfangszeit, wenn ich gerade irgendwas Besonderes ist und gehen dann.
Bis sie fertig sind quasi oder auch nicht, aber maximal bis um zwölf Uhr nachts,
dann machen die Stenographenfeierabend, die haben nämlich im Gegensatz zu uns eine Gewerkschaft und dürfen dann nicht mehr oder müssen dann nicht mehr.
So
Häufig passiert, sage ich mal, dass wirklich eine Sitzung auch bis um zwölf Uhr nachts ging,
Dann machen die Schluss. Manchmal ist es eben auch so, dass nach der öffentlichen Sitzung noch eine nicht öffentliche Sitzung ist, wenn dann eben aufgefallen ist in der Sitzung, die Zeugen,
können noch was zu Sachen sagen, zu denen die Öffentlichkeit jetzt nichts erfahren soll, dann hängen die das noch
aber da dürfen wir natürlich nicht mehr dabei sein. Aber immer so nachts um zwölf ist Schluss und dann ist ein Cut,
dann ist auch vorbei.
Aber das ist so die Sitzung vorbei, dann ist es für euch noch nicht vorbei, weil dann müssen die Notizen natürlich nochmal zusammen äh,
werden. Okay, das meiste ist dann auch mehr oder weniger direkt online, ne? Also der, das Protokoll entsteht ja live.
Genau, wir haben dort Live-Blog und das Live-Blog schreiben, wenn wir natürlich während der Sitzung, aber wenn man das halt so mitschreibt, dann macht man halt irgendwie eine Menge an Rechtschreibfehlern, da muss man nochmal Sachen aufbereiten, dann hat man vielleicht irgendwo,
Was nicht richtig verstanden und muss das nochmal nachgucken und dann kann man schon so damit rechnen, dass die Nachbereitung von so einem Protokoll mindestens genauso lange dauert, wie die Sitzung. Das heißt, wir versuchen dann auch.
Nicht das Ding nur rechtschreib zu korrigieren, sondern es irgendwie auch ein bisschen durchsuchbarer zu machen, Links zu setzen, anstellen, wo halt nicht selbsterklärend ist, was die Frage jetzt eigentlich meint, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel gefragt wird so,
Was waren mit diesem Spion, der da bei ihnen war und da wird dann,
kein Kontext gegeben, weil die haben ja immer nur eine begrenzte Redezeit und die versuchen sich halt knapp zu fassen, die Abgeordneten, weil es ja so ist, dass.
Oppositionsfraktion jeweils nur acht Minuten pro Stunde fragen darf und den Rest kriegen eben SPD und Union, deshalb sind die Fragen halt auch knapp und manchmal versteht man dann so gar nicht so richtig, was wollen, was wollen die gerade hinaus und dann versuchen wir halt da nochmal links zu setzen und nochmal Sachen zu erklären vielleicht,
das nochmal aufzubereiten und dann natürlich irgendwie unsere ganzen Abkürzungen irgendwie,
auszuformulieren, weil wir halt in der Sitzung irgendwie ganz viel mit Kurzschreibweisen arbeiten, was halt auch nicht so leserfreundlich ist und,
auszuformulieren. Also da braucht man schon quasi eine Sitzung und nochmal die Zeit vor einer Sitzung mindestens, um das dann irgendwie aufzubereiten.
Hättest du meine Stilographie äh Ausbildung gemacht?
Ich habe kurz drüber nachgedacht tatsächlich, dann habe ich mir mal so ein paar Stenoprogramme für so irgendwie Tastatur und so angeguckt, das ist irgendwie und habe ich gedacht, da brauche ich jetzt mindestens ein Jahr, bis ich das gelernt habe, das bringt dann auch nicht mehr viel, falls der nächste Ausschuss kommt, kann ich nochmal drüber nachdenken
Aber erstmal versuchen wir das so so gut es geht. Genau,
vielleicht nochmal kurz sagen, warum wir das eigentlich machen, man könnte sich ja so überlegen, so eigentlich im Bundestag wird ja alles protokolliert.
Aber beschlossen wurde, dass es zu diesen Sitzungen erstmal keine öffentlichen Protokolle gibt. Und zwar aus,
Der offiziellen Begründung raus, dass die Zeugen nicht beeinflusst werden sollen, das heißt,
irgendwie ein paar Leute vom BND geladen werden, die zum Thema Aussagen sollen, dann soll es eben nicht der Fall sein, dass der zweite Zeuge lesen,
Können soll, was der Erste gesagt.
War dann eben auch die Begründung warum es keine Protokolle für die Öffentlichkeit geben soll. Wir fanden die Begründung total schwachsinnig, weil,
Zum einen ist es eben so, dass die BND Leute sicherlich ihre anderen Informationsquellen haben, um sich zu irgendwie,
legen was ihr Vorgänger da gesagt hat, mit dem sie wahrscheinlich auch noch im selben Büro sitzen
und auf der anderen Seite ist es eben auch für die Öffentlichkeit ein riesiges Problem, weil nicht,
jede Zeitungsredaktion kann sich da irgendwie leisten jedes Mal jemanden hinzuschicken für einen halben Tag und dementsprechend wollen wir das irgendwie anbieten,
und es ist auch die einzige öffentlich ausführliche Dokumentation von diesem Ausschuss, weil selbst wenn jetzt
große Zeitungen drüber schreiben, so wie Zeit, das machen, SZ das zum Teil machen, dann ist das natürlich auch immer nur ein Ausschnitt, weil die haben halt auch 'ne Begren,
Ressourcen und da wollen wir zumindest die Möglichkeit geben, dass Leute das irgendwie im Ganzen nachgucken und schauen, was da
im Ganzen gelaufen ist.
Ist schon ein bisschen absurd, oder?
Ist ein bisschen absurd, vor allem sollen ja nach derzeitigen Angaben diese ganzen Protokolle, nachdem der Ausschuss vorbei ist, veröffentlicht werden, das heißt, die haben ja gesagt, so, wenn das alles durch ist mit dem Ausschuss irgendwann, dann werfen wir die ins Internet.
Aber wir haben zum Beispiel auch gesehen, es gab ein Protokoll schon das veröffentlicht wurde.
Das war nämlich eine Sitzung mit einem Zeugen, die zwar öffentlich war, aber der Zeuge hatte so einen Persönlichkeitsschutz, das heißt, den durfte keiner sehen, das heißt, die Öffentlichkeit durfte da nicht drin sitzen.
Gucken wer dieser Mensch ist und da wurde eben gesagt, okay, dann machen wir so einen Kompromiss, dann stellen wir das Protokoll davon online, das haben sie dann auch gemacht.
Wir haben ganz oft die Situation, dass Leuten in Sitzungen quasi so ein bisschen was rausrutscht, da gab's auch schon mal Leute, die haben dann irgendwelche Klarnamen gesagt, aus Versehen.
Bei denen wir aber erwarten, dass sie dann in den Protokollen, die am Ende.
Für die Öffentlichkeit vom Bundestag bereit gestellt werden auch geschwärzt sein werden, das heißt ich glaube auch wenn jetzt später mal diese ganzen Protokolle kommen so wie sie quasi bei uns stehen werden sie erstmal nicht.
Also das ist aber wirklich eine Situation,
ist das eigentlich eine Regelung, die generell für Ausschüsse gilt äh also für Untersuchungsausschüsse gilt oder ist es eine Regelung, die nur für diesen Untersuchungsausschuss gilt.
Das war soweit ich mich erinnere, war das eine Absprache für diesen Ausschuss. Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, aber ich glaube, das muss so nicht. Also die können sich dazu entscheiden Sachen.
Zu veröffentlichen. Es gab ja auch für die.
Ein paar Sitzungen, wo Sachverständige geladen wurden, gab's ja teilweise sogar Videoaufzeichnungen,
dann irgendwie auch bereitgestellt wurden. Ich glaube, dass mehr oder weniger eine individuelle Entscheidung,
man sich halt auch nochmal klar machen muss, gerade wenn man sich die BND Leute so anguckt,
der halt eben diese BND Zeugen vertritt und man kann sich halt überlegen, wenn alle Zeugen einen gleichen Anwalt haben,
dass sie dann irgendwie nicht wissen, was ihr Vorgänger gesagt hat oder dass sie nicht gesagt bekommen, was sie denn jetzt besser zu sagen haben, ist halt irgendwie alles so ein bisschen lächerlich.
Und mittlerweile gibt es eigentlich, glaube ich, niemanden mehr, der sich ernsthaft darüber aufregt, dass wir das machen. Am Anfang gab's immer noch so ein paar CDU-Abgeordnete, die ja so ein bisschen,
waren und da so ein bisschen gegen gewettet haben, aber mittlerweile wird ja selbst irgendwie was auch immer so ein bisschen eine absurde,
Situation ist von den BND-Zeugen geloopt, das ist diese Protokolle zum Beispiel gibt und wir haben uns schon so ein bisschen ausgemalt wie der BND dann keine Ahnung mit Kaffee und Kuchen irgendwie in Bad Aibling und in Pullach sitzt und sich dann diese Protokolle live durchs,
um mal zu gucken, was der Kollege gerade so erzählt.
Erstmal Netzpolitik ordentlich lesen beim Geheimdienst wieder up zu date zu sein. Ist schon, das ist schon wirklich haarsträubend so und äh ja,
schönes Beispiel für diese ja Absurdität des des nicht digitalen, die sich immer wieder so entfaltet. Also ich habe sehr viel Arbeit damit.
Mich überrascht, dass es jetzt ehrlich gesagt, dass du sagst, nochmal sozusagen nochmal ein ganzer Tag, um das Ding dann fertig zu machen, aber es ist ja dann auch nicht selten, um Mitternacht noch nicht mal Schluss, weil es ja dann auch mitgemacht bei dem Podcast, technische Aufklärung.
Äh Jonas und Felix gestartet haben. Ähm bis dahin oben.
Verlaufe des der Serie irgendwann dazu gestoßen, ne.
Genau, ich war dann am Anfang war halt Andre immer dabei, weil er die Protokolle dann noch gemacht hat, als er dann irgendwie im Urlaub war, habe ich das dann mitgemacht und
Die beiden haben das gestartet und das sollte glaube ich erstmal nur eine einmalige Sendung werden zum Thema und haben dann eben gemerkt, Mensch, das wäre ein ziemlich spannendes Thema und das ist ja relativ unterrepräsentiert, gerade so,
so die ganzen Podcasts angeht und das wollen sie weiter machen und das hat sich mittlerweile auch echt zu einer,
Gruppe entwickelt, da sind auch öfter mal noch andere Leute dabei, zum Bei,
Daniel Lücking ist irgendwie regelmäßig dabei oder Cebas ist regelmäßig dabei und dann gibt's zum Teil auch noch Gäste, die jetzt,
Letztes Mal haben wir noch irgendwie mit Falk Steiner besprochen, auch ein Journalist, der den Ausschuss regelmäßig begleitet oder wir haben auch schon mal Sonderfolgen gemacht, zum Beispie
Mit Kai Biermann zum Thema Exkiescore, um da noch so ein bisschen Kontext zu geben und ich glaube, das ist einfach eine gute Möglichkeit, sich.
Den Podcast auch immer direkt nach der Sitzung, das führt teilweise dazu, dass.
Wenn jetzt die Sitzung erst um zwölf zu Ende war, dass wir dann so ein bisschen Matschig im Gehirn sind und das merkt man
teilweise auch, aber ich glaube, es ist auch einfach mal ein guter Eindruck, was gerade so von dem Tag hängengeblieben ist oder was
wirklich die Eindrücke waren auch so von der ganzen Atmosphäre oder von den ganzen Hintergründen und nicht nur von den sage ich mal harten Fakten.
Ja, ich finde auch, dass es eine super Ergänzung, weil eigentlich im Prinzip ja auch dadurch beide Medien eigentlich optimal nutzt,
auf dem Punkt ist und dann äh.
Auf der anderen Seite halt der Podcast, der so ein bisschen auch so ein bisschen die Metaspielwiese ist, ne, wo man Eindrücke vermittelt und äh,
ja, auch so, man bisschen die Gefühle sprechen, äh, lassen kann.
Genau und ich glaube, es trägt sich auch ganz gut, weil wir auch relativ viel Rückmeldungen bekommen von Leuten, die jetzt sagen, sie wollen jetzt dieses Live-Blog nicht durchlesen, weil das ist ja auch einfach,
viel Material und es ist ja jetzt irgendwie auch kein Vergnügen, sich da so Stichwort Sätze durchzulesen irgendwie am laufenden Bande und die dann eben sagen, das ist so wirklich ihre
Hauptinformationsquelle, gerade bei Sitzungen, wo jetzt nicht so die prominenten Zeugen sitzen und nicht die großen,
Sage ich mal, Online-Medien, da nochmal extra drüber berichten und das zeigt sich auch dadurch, dass.
Die technische Aufklärung jetzt für den Krim Online Award nominiert wurde. Das hat alle sehr überrascht. Damit hätte erstmal keiner gerechnet und wir waren alle ziemlich ziemlich,
freut darüber und da vielleicht noch so ein kleiner Werbeblock, da kann man auch noch abstimmen für den Publikumskreis von Grimma Online Award, da muss man mal schauen, ich glaube, wir packen den Link dann mal,
in die Shownote. Ich habe den gerade nicht im Kopf.
Das machen wir auf jeden Fall. Ja.
Du sagtest ja schon so am Anfang äh fühlten sich auch einige so ein bisschen unwohl mit dieser äh Berichterstattung. Wir hatten ja dann auch den Fall von äh André und seiner Spezialbegleitung, wo er dann äh diesen Hauspolizisten äh äh im Rücken hatte, auch äh da hatten wir, glaube ich, immer eine
hat sich das normalisiert, ja? Also ihr seid jetzt so ähm akzeptierter Bestandteil.
Ja, also zumindest mit dieser Polizeibegleitung, die jetzt, sage ich mal, in unserem Rückensitz, haben wir keine Probleme mehr
da sitzt immer Polizei auf dieser Tribüne um, das heißt, man muss sich das ja so vorstellen, unten im Saal sitzt ein,
Die Abgeordneten, die Zeugen und die sogenannten Hinterbänkler, die dann,
von dem Ministerium kommen und aufpassen, dass sie nichts falsches sagen und nicht zu viel sagen und so weiter und so.
Und dann oben auf der Besuchertribüne ist halt meistens dann auch die Bundestagspolizei zu gegen, die passt dann irgendwie auf so Sachen auf, wie das niemand, was oben von der Tribüne runter wirft. Manchmal sagen sie einem auch, man soll sich ordentlich hinsetzen, aber zumindest so, dass man sie im Rücken sitzen hat, dass,
Das fangen sie jetzt nicht mehr an, das versucht gerade keiner mehr. Wir haben teilweise noch so ein paar absurde Situationen.
Gerade so in den letzten Sitzungen als Leute vom Verfassungsschutz eben ausgesagt haben,
dann auch oben auf den Bänken Leute vom Verfassungsschutz, die dann,
auch teilweise nicht als solche zu erkennen waren und dann irgendwie mit dem normalen Besucherschildchen da reingegangen sind und die dann auf Nachfrage, wo sie denn herkämen, irgendwie meinten, na ja, sie sind aus einer nachgeordneten Behörde des Innenministeriums, also,
kann man sich dann schon so ein bisschen seine Gedanken zu machen.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht die korrekte Art, sich dann da als Besucher hinzusetzen,
irgendwie sich zu tarnen, aber na ja, so sind sie halt, ne.
Ach Gottchen. Ähm,
Blätter mir nochmal ein bisschen nochmal äh zurück. Dieser Untersuchungsausschuss läuft ja nun auch schon sehr lange. Weiß gar nicht, wann fing das überhaupt an.
Er fing im Frühjahr zweitausendvierzehn an.
Das heißt, man hatte ja dann im Juni zwei dreizehn, kamen ja so die ersten Slowen Geschichten raus und dann,
hat man irgendwann, nachdem man diese Spielaffäre ja beendet hat, irgendwie durch den Hempofaller und dann irgendwann gemerkt hat, Mensch, ist vielle,
noch nicht so ganz vorbei
war dann der Wunsch nach einem Untersuchungsausschuss laut, das war auch der erste Untersuchungsausschuss in der Wahlperiode, das muss man sich ja auch nochmal so ein bisschen vor Augen führen, dass man ja dann quasi direkt nach diesen Snowen Geschichten die Bundestagswahlen hatte
nach diesen Bundestagswahlen, nachdem man dann eine Regierung gebildet hatte, war klar, man muss das untersuchen und dann hat man eben diesen Ausschuss eingesetzt, was auch.
Relativ,
Sage ich mal erfreulich gelaufen ist, weil es da zumindest über die Einsetzung des Ausschusses, dass man den braucht, keine Uneinigkeit zwischen den Fraktionen gab, das heißt, sowohl Opposition als auch die GroKo haben gesagt, so, wir wollen so einen Ausschuss haben,
Die Verhandlungen liefen dann eher so im Detail des Untersuchungsauftrags, das heißt das, was man sich schriftlich gibt, was man untersuchen will und darf. Da sieht man dann auch,
aber zumindest der Wille zum Untersuchen diese,
Themas war bei beiden Seiten erstmal vorhanden.
Und das war ja nicht selbstverständlich, dass der überhaupt so ohne weiteres eingesetzt wird, weil mit den neuen Mehrheitsverhältnissen hätte die Opposition äh glaube ich gar nicht die notwendige Stimmzahl zusammengebracht, also.
Na ja, das kann man so nicht ganz sagen, weil es gibt ja sogenannte Minderheitenrecht bei der Einsetzung von einem Untersuchungsausschuss und das Minderheitenrecht sagt, dass man,
nur fünfundzwanzig Prozent der Stimmen braucht, um einen Untersuchungsausschuss einzusetzen, eben gerade um das Untersuchungsrecht von der Opposition zu stärken, auch gegen die Regierungskoalition,
Jetzt haben wir halt im aktuellen Bundestag das Problem, dass die Opposition ja nicht mal fünfundzwanzig,
hat und da gab es,
sozusagen eine Bereitschaftserklärung, diese Regelung, die.
Für die parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschüsse geregelt ist auch.
In dem Fall, in dieser Legislatur,
Für weniger als diese fünfundzwanzig Prozent gelten zu lassen, sprich für die beiden Oppositionsfraktionen. Das ist natürlich so eine gute Regelung, da könnte man das ist sicherlich nicht alles hundertprozentig sicher, aber zumindest gab's eben diese Absichtserklärung, dass das möglich sein soll und,
das wurde dann dementsprechend auch erstmal so gehandhabt, war aber in dem Fall auch gar nicht nötig.
Bayer ähm bisher jetzt gerade eine Abstimmung gab, äh beim Bundesverfassungsgericht, nachdem Gregor Gisi, glaube ich, geklagt hatte.
Und das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat jetzt sozusagen festgestellt, dass diese Sonderregelung jetzt nicht unbedingt ähm.
Genau, die ist nicht verpflich.
Forderlich nicht verpflichtend gewesen wäre, genau.
Das ist quasi mehr oder weniger so ein guter Wille, den man irgendwie,
zeigt oder vorgibt, aber ich sage mal, wenn man irgendwas verhindern will, könnte man natürlich immer sagen, so, nee, machen wir nicht.
Aber sieht halt erstmal nicht so schön aus, ne? Also ich meine, wenn man dann sagt irgendwie so, wir unterdrücken jetzt die Opposition noch ein bisschen mehr und nehmen mir quasi auch so dieses irgendwie Minderheitenrecht, dann sieht das einfach nicht so schick aus.
Die Zusammensetzung des Untersuchungsausschusses fand ich auch noch
In seiner Zusammensetzung spiegelt dann eben auch die Mehrheitsverhältnisse im Parlament wider, das heißt so wie man eben in den Fraktionen äh stärkenmäßig vertreten ist, so ist man auch im Untersuchungsausschuss vertreten, das heißt die schlechte Situation der Opposition hat sich dann auch in diesem Untersuchungsausschuss deutlich
niedergeschlagen. Ähm dann gab's ja zu Beginn gleich äh,
Weiß nicht, ob man da von einem Eklat sprechen kann, aber zumindest das,
Problem des designierte Vorsitzende im Prinzip relativ schnell wieder in den Hut genommen hat. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, wie hieß der Vogel nochmal, der.
Kiesewetter. Genau, das da war am Anfang schon die Sache, der ist irgendwann einfach zurückgetreten,
und aber dann so weniger als ein Jahr also genau der ist weniger als ein Jahr nach Einsetzung des Ausschusses irgendwie zurückgetreten und
hat dann erstmal Gründe angegeben wie ja Überlastung schafft er nicht dieses und jenes, was irgendwie alle so ein bisschen überrascht hat, weil er irgendwie erstmal relativ ehrgeizig schien so in
dieser Aufgabe und dann gab's dann Veröffentlichung von der Welt.
Eigentlich einen anderen Grund gehabt hätte, nämlich dass er.
Zurückgezogen hätte, weil in seinem Umfeld so.
Doppelagenten irgendwas mit russischem Geheimdienst gewesen wäre und BND, dass es da grade in diesem Reservistenverband, in dem man da ist,
Probleme gegeben hätte und dass er sich dann deshalb zurückgezogen habe bevor ihm so eine Voreingenommenheit vorgeworfen wird oder eine Beeinflussung.
Also es lässt sich sozusagen nicht belegen, dass er ein russischer Spion ist.
Ich glaube so hundertprozentig äh richtige Belege, dass da irgendwas mit russischen Spionen drin war, wie so oft haben wir natürlich nicht.
Ja
Dann kam aber auch also für Kiesewetter kam dann der äh Herr Sensburg von der Unionsfraktion als Vorsitzender in den Ausschuss.
'ne relativ interessante Art und Weise, wenn man das so sagen darf, also er.
Ich hatte immer so die Assoziation äh dass Günther Jauch, dass Untersuchungsausschusses, weil er so ein bisschen irgendwie so diese Rolle von dem freundlichen Onkel von nebenan spielt und man sich mal so ein bisschen fragt so, jetzt meint er das jetzt ernst, was hat er jetzt eigentlich wirklich so für eine Meinung.
Und das kann man irgendwie gut oder schlecht finden. Ich kann das nicht so richtig für mich persönlich beeinflussen,
Also einschätzen, manchmal merkt man aber auch, dass er eben durch diese nette Onkel-Rolle teilweise Zeugen zum.
Prinzip, weil sind ja irgendwie die bösen Linken und Grünen und die wollen uns ja nur Böses und bei ihm hat man eben dieses Gefühl nicht,
so ein bisschen dieses juviale Gefühl und da kommen halt teilweise Sachen raus, die glaube ich anderweitig nicht rauskommen würden auf der anderen Seite muss man natürlich auch sagen, dass es halt,
oftmals auch Fragen dann unter den Tisch fallen, die dann wiederum irgendwie die Opposition stellen muss, was sie teilweise einfach auch nicht beantwortet bekommt, also.
Genau. Aber ich glaube, er spielt zumindest diese Rolle von den netten Vorsitzenden. Äh in einer ganz interessanten Art und Weise, die man sich auch äh gerne mal live angucken kann.
Manchmal ist er auch wütend, also manchmal äh hat er auch schlechte Laune, das ist dann immer ganz überraschend. Zum Bei,
in der Sitzung am letzten Donnerstag war es dann so, dass er irgendwann als dann.
Der Herr Ackmann vom BMI, der.
Hinter Bank sitzt und eigentlich kein Rederecht in diesem Ausschuss hat, dem.
Also vom Innenministerium, ne.
Genau vom Innenministerium, dem Zeugen irgendwie sagen wollte.
Mensch, jetzt hör doch mal auf zu reden, erzähl nicht so viel, weil der plötzlich irgendwann angefangen hat sind wir wieder im Thema von den,
sich ja eigentlich nicht unaufgefordert zu Wort melden sollte, kam dann der Herr Senzburg und meinte so, jetzt aktuell jetzt seien sie endlich mal still, ich verweise sie jetzt das Salz und da war erstmal so Ruhe, ist da noch nichts passiert, aber der Herr Aktmann saß erstmal zwei Stunden lang,
dann irgendwie zumindest in diesen Momenten, wo dann wirklich so ein bisschen,
auf den Tisch gehauen wird, irgendwie relativ überraschend von ihm ist und dann zumindest auch, glaube ich, äh die Regierung sei ein bisschen verunsichert hat.
Welche Person würdest du denn? Wir wollen müssen ja nicht die ganze Liste durchgehen, aber welche welche Persönlichkeiten sind dir denn jetzt im Untersuchungsausschuss noch äh aufgefallen,
Also ich denke, die Opposition ist auf jeden Fall noch bemerkenswert, aber vielleicht nochmal kurz auch bei der Ausrichtung der Koalition zu bleiben.
Die sage ich mal, die Koalition hat ja insgesamt acht Leute offiziell in diesem Ausschuss sitzen,
es ist auch nicht so, dass die immer alle da sind, das heißt, oftmals fehlen einfach relativ viele Leute von denen, weil die sind ja gen,
die müssen ja nur ihre Fragen durchbringen und das ist ja nicht,
wenn gerade auch andere Ausschüsse parallel sind. Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass dieser Ausschuss an diesem Tag alleine stattfindet, dann teilen die sich so ein bisschen auf, aber man sieht halt die Leute, die immer wieder da sitzen oder die regelmäßig dasitzen, das ist zum Beispiel von der SPD gerade der,
Christian Fliesek, der da sitzt, der sag ich mal so das tut was man von so einem SPDler erwartet würde ich sagen, also
der stellt jetzt irgendwie nicht die unglaublich kritischen Fragen, aber kann auch, sage ich mal, sehr energisch sein, gerade bei Themen
irgendwie wichtig sind oder er hat auch irgendwie öfter mal so die Angewohnheit so ein bisschen auf dem moralischen Aspekten rumzuhauen und dann zu sagen, so ja wie können sie sowas oder wie können sie sowas irgendwie
einfach nicht in Frage stellen und das kann doch überhaupt nicht sein und gerade auch bei der ganzen.
Geflüchteten Thematik, die da im Zusammenhang mit Befragung durch,
emotional auch äh appelliert investiert an eben die Zeugen. Und auf.
Der Union, aber seine Fragezeit geht quasi nicht von der Fragezeit der Union ab.
Ihre siebenundzwanzig Minuten hat, wenn ich mich jetzt irgendwie, also siebenundzwanzig Minuten von einer Stunde, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht falsch erinnere, sondern da sitzen dann noch andere Leute, zum Beispiel.
Viel da ist Nina Wagen von der Union, die oftmals vielleicht so ein paar lapidare Fragen stellt, die aber auch glaube ich,
in ihrem Hintergrund, also.
Von der Arbeit im Ausschuss machen ja auch die Mitarbeiter der jeweiligen Fraktion und Abgeordne,
die dann eben sich durch die Akten wühlen und das aufbereiten und auch mal gucken, was man so für Fragen stellen kann. Wo dann immer wieder,
ab und zu interessante Fundstellen aus den Dokumenten eben vorgebracht werden von ihr. Dann haben wir natürlich noch so sage ich mal Auftritte wie den Herrn Schipanski, der.
Einfach eine unglaublich amüsante Rolle spielt, teilweise so teilweise bringt er einen unglaublich zur Weißglut, weil er,
Oftmals er fragt eigentlich nie Dinge, die irgendwie substanziell wären, sondern er fragt einfach nur Dinge zur Selbstbestätigung, dass alles so in Ordnung ist, wie es ist,
fragt er zum Beispiel, na ja, haben sie das dann gemeldet? Und dann meinte der andere so,
Jahr habe ich gemacht und dann kommt von ihm so die Aussage, naja, dann sehen wir ja, das hat ja alles gut geklappt und wir wollen ihnen ja auch nichts vorwerfen und wir wollen sie auch unterstützen und eigentlich ist er so der,
klassische Geheimdienstapologie, der dann jedes Mal hingeht und irgendwie versucht durch seine Suggesti,
die einfach teilweise schon peinlich suggestiv sind, irgendwie,
klarzustellen der Öffentlichkeit, dass alles total super läuft und man da eigentlich dem BND und dem Verfassungsschutz nur ein paar mehr Mittel geben muss und dann klappt das auch.
Nicht so geklappt, da hat er irgendwie teilweise auch schon Zeugen gefragt, so, naja, glauben sie denn, dieses Meldesystem bei ihnen funktioniert und wenn dann der Zeuge eben nein sagt, dann ist das für den Herrn Schipanski ein kleines Problem, dann weiß er nämlich nicht, nicht mehr so richtig weiter und hält dann auch die Klappe, aber zumindest sorgen seine Fragen.
Wenn man dich gerade irgendwie aggressiv dabei wird, äh, teilweise für Erheiterung und für Lachen im Saal.
Und ich glaube eine Person, die man noch irgendwie erwähnen muss, über die auch viel geredet wurde, ist der Her,
Wolf vom Bundeskanzleramt, das ist auch einer von den Leuten, die in den hinteren Reihen sitzen und die gerade bei den,
Zeugen vom BND, der BND ist ja quasi eine Behörde so im,
oder unter der Fach- und Dienstaufsicht des Bundeskanzleramtes. Wir führen die BND Zeugen eben aufpasst, dass sie innerhalb ihrer Aussagegenehmigung bleiben, das heißt, dass sie nicht mehr sagen, als sie sagen dürfen.
Also unterbricht.
Das ist der, der immer unterbricht und sagt jetzt hier, das ist jetzt aber nicht Untersuchungsgegenstand oder das ist eine Sache, die nur in der nicht öffentlichen Sitzung besprochen werden darf oder das liegt nicht im Untersuchungszeitraum, das heißt, wir haben ja auch das Problem, dass der Zeitraum.
Erstmal nur bis zu dem Punkt der Einsetzung dieses Untersuchungsausschusses ging und danach natürlich noch ganz viel passiert ist, was nicht gefragt werden darf.
Und der da immer so ein bisschen quasi die Rolle dessen einnimmt, der die Zeugen so zurückruft.
Und der auch eine ganz interessante Person ist, da gab's mal eine
schönes Porträt von Kai Biermann auf Z-Online zu ihm und man weiß auch nicht so richtig,
herkommt. Man ist sich relativ sicher, dass,
mit seinem, sage ich mal, verschmitzten Lächeln, mit dem er da sitzt, teilweise wirkt das so, als wäre das für ihn alles ein großes, amüsantes Theater, glaube ich, eine ganz interessante Person, gerade zu der Befragung von den BND-Zeugen.
Mhm. Ähm.
Den unerwarteten Rücktritt von diesem Ruderich Kieselwetter ähm als Vorsitzenden gesprochen.
Ach so, ich glaube, wir haben das ein bisschen verkackt. Der war nämlich äh Kiesewetter war nämlich Obmann und Binninger war Vorsitzender,
Das ist so, dass jede Fraktion, das heißt, die Grünen, die Linken, die SPD und die Union benennen jeweils eine Obperson oder ein,
der dann sozusagen ihr Hauptbeauftragte in diesem Ausschuss ist. Das ist jetzt irgendwie.
So dass die sich auch in extra Runden treffen. Das sind sozusagen die sogenannten Obleute-Runden, wo nochmal irgendwie Sachen extra besprochen werden, dass das zum Beispiel auch Leute sind, die.
Als es darum ging, BND-Selektoren einzusehen, als so dieses Angebot kam, ging dieses Angebot eben auch nur an die Obleute und eben nicht an die anderen Abgeordneten im Ausschuss, das quasi nochmal so ein bisschen eine Sonderrolle, so ein bisschen wie.
In der Fraktion Vorsitzende oder Beauftragte für diesen Ausschuss.
Mhm. So, der der zurückgetretene Vorsitzende war dann wiederum Clemens Binninger.
Genau, Binninger, den habe ich nämlich irgendwie schon fast vergessen, der war nämlich eigentlich nur,
eine Woche in dieser Rolle und ist quasi schon direkt nach der ersten Sitzung wieder abgetreten.
Weil er eben einmal gesagt hat, er hat irgendwie keinen Bock auf diesen Streit, um etwas Snowden als Zeugen für den Ausschuss, wo sich ja einfach viel Öffentlichkeit auch dran entsponnen hat und meinte dann so, er hat überhaupt keine,
Hoffnung, dass das sich irgendwie verträglich regeln lässt und nicht irgendwie total ausartet.
Auf der anderen Seite war natürlich auch.
Vorsitzende vom parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium und.
Da gibt's natürlich so, sage ich mal, man könnte das als Vorteil sehen, dass parlamentarische Kontrollgremium ist ja sozusagen, dass eines der beiden Gremien im Bundestag oder.
Im Bundestagsumfeld, dass die Geheimdienste kontrollieren soll und da hatte,
gleichen Leute im Ausschuss zu Themen befragt werden, wie auch im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium und,
hat man nochmal das Problem, dass alles, was das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium macht, geheim ist, das heißt,
trinkt quasi gar nicht so richtig nach außen und da hat man natürlich das Problem, dieses Wissen dann auseinanderzuhalten. Und das Problem hat man auch bei so
Abgeordneten wie dem Hans-Christian Ströbele von den Grünen, der für die im Ausschuss sitzt, der schon
richtig, richtig lange eben Mitglied in diesem Kontrollgremium ist, der immer wieder sich bremsen muss, weil er eben
sein Wissen aus diesem Gremium nicht in diesen Ausschuss reinbringen darf, der muss sich dazu sagen, irgendwie seine Persönlichkeit spalten und muss ich sagen, okay, ich darf es jetzt wieder fragen, aus Versehen, noch Wissen, noch irgendwie suggerieren, sonst kriege ich nämlich so ein bisschen Ärger und das glaube ich.
Ist natürlich eine problematische Rolle.
Dann sollten wir vielleicht nochmal auch auf die Vertreter der Opposition blicken, die ja in gewisser Hinsicht noch sehr viel.
Mehr Eindruck hinter äh hinterlassen und zumindest in meiner Wahrnehmung.
Genau, da haben wir vier Mitglieder, da haben wir zum einen den Konstantin von Notz, der Obmann für die Grünen im Ausschuss ist und den Hans-Christian Ströbele, der.
Eben auch durch seine Arbeit im parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium einfach schon ewig lange Erfahrungen mit diesen ganzen Geheimdiensten in Deutschland hat und da.
Und noch länger mit raff und überhaupt seit den siebziger Jahren eigentlich dauerhaft
verbunden ist, an der Stelle sei, vielleicht auch nochmal kurz äh hier verwiesen für Leute, die Lok Bodles Politik vielleicht noch nicht so lange hören und äh,
vor allem noch nicht alles nachgehört haben
Wir hatten ja mal hier eine Jubiläumsausgabe, äh die Nummer hundert und äh unter dem schönen Titel gehört schon zum Establishment. Äh, da haben wir uns ja
mit Hans-Christian Ströble unterhalten über all diese ganzen Meter äh Komplexe, über Macht und Staat und Revolution, Geheimdienste, Unrecht und Freiheit und äh ja, das mal hier so als kleiner, interner Werbeblock.
Genau, ich glaube, man kann auch so ein bisschen sagen, dass vielleicht ein bisschen überspi,
aber ich sag mal der, der Hans-Christian Ströbel hat hier einfach massenweise Erfahrung mit den Geheimdiensten und der Konstantin von Notz ist ja auch
Netzpolitisch für die Grünen irgendwie sehr aktiv, da könnte man so ein bisschen sagen, Notz macht alles, was so mit diesem Internet und diesen neueren Kommunikationsmedien und
Der Ströbele ist dann eben wirklich der Geheimdiensterfahrene, der da sitzt und ich glaube, die beiden ergänzen sich auch in dieser Rolle ganz gut und machen dann ziemlich gute Arbeit.
Gott sei Dank wird immer unglaublich ausgeschlafen. Also.
Die es dann so die die Presse Statements nach nach der Ausschützsitzung entscheiden wir ja mal.
Na ja, ich glaube,
man muss sich auch irgendwie mal klar machen, was so eine Ausschusssitzung bedeutet. Ich meine, sie sitzen da ja auch stundenlang und versuchen, sich irgendwie zu konzentrieren und wenn man dann da unten sitzt und seine Fragen,
und diese Fragen irgendwie zum dreißigsten Mal nicht beantwortet
bekommt oder auf eine Art und Weise beantwortet bekommt, dass man den am liebsten irgendwie faule Eier ins Gesicht werden
werfen würde und das aber einfach mal nicht kann, dann ist man glaube ich auch schon ziemlich angespannt. Das kann ich, glaube ich, nach so einer Sitzung niemandem verüb.
Ja, nachvollzieht, aber es ist sieht trotzdem sehr nach wenig Schlaf aus und das ist wahrscheinlich auch einfach so.
Aber das ist auch so, ja.
Ich hoffe, äh die ruinieren sich nicht ihre äh Gesundheit dabei, aber tun sie wahrscheinlich trotzdem. So dann haben wir ja noch die Linken.
Genau, da haben wir die Linken, da haben wir die Martina Renner und den Andre Hahn im Ausschuss,
Frau Rinner ist irgendwie relativ also eigentlich fast immer da, der Hahn jetzt nicht unbedingt jedes Mal, aber auch und,
die machen da auch sehr viel Arbeit und haben da glaube ich auch irgendwie sehr gute Mitarbeiter, die ihnen helfen, diese Do2-Dokumente zu durchsuchen und legen auch immer wieder interessante Dokumente vor, die eben dann auch die Zeugen damit konfrontieren, dass das, was sie gerade gesagt haben,
nicht unbedingt der Wahrheit entspricht oder dass es in Dokumenteninformationen gibt, dass es da andere.
Zugeben könnte und glaube das ist auch ganz wichtig, weil sonst steht man ja mehr oder weniger in so einem luftleeren Raum.
Und kann denen ja nicht richtig was nachweisen, man weiß ja nichts darüber und eben die einzigen Anhaltspunkte sind, diese Dokumente, die die,
Ausschussmitglieder haben, aber da kann man jetzt auch nicht so einfach sagen, ne, wenn sie die Dokumente haben, dann können sie das ja alles rausfinden, so,
Ist einfach ein unglaubliches Ausmaß an Papier und Nichtpapier. Das kann man vielleicht auch nochmal kurz erklären, nämlich das ist so, dass sie.
Bekommen zu Beweisbeschlüssen, die sie eben anfordern, das heißt sie sagen wir,
jetzt gerne zu diesem und jenem Thema alles was ihr habt,
Das geht dann zum Beispiel an den BND, an den Ministerien und so weiter und dann bekommen sie das,
im Idealfall und da ist es erstmal so, dass die ganzen Sachen, die.
NFD sind, das heißt oder niedriger, also nicht für den Dienst, nicht nur für den Dienst. Wir brauchen nicht.
Dass die Sachen digital angeliefert werden,
aber alles was darüber eingestuft ist, sprich vertraulich, geheim und streng geheim eben erstmal nur auf totem Baum dasteht und das heißt natürlich irgendwie Schränke voller Ak.
Akten, die man jetzt nicht mit Steuerung F nach irgendeinem Thema durchsuchen kann. Das heißt, man hat irgendwie riesige Mengen,
und da muss man sich erstmal durchwühlen, das heißt auch.
Oftmals wurde auch so ein bisschen berichtet von den Abgeordneten, wie sie damit arbeiten und da hat man dann auch noch das Problem, dass teilweise Akten vielleicht NFD eingestuft sind, aber Teile davon dann geheim sind, dann steht dann,
anscheinend sieht das dann so aus, dass dann in diesem Dokument steht, dieser Teil ist jetzt rausgenommen, dafür gehst du jetzt bitte in die Geheimschutzstelle, das irgendwie.
Des Bundestages oder Bundeskanzleramtes und dann musst du dahin laufen.
Musst du die Stelle merken, dass dir dann da vielleicht sogar, wenn die Sachen wirklich geheim sind, keine Notizen zu machen.
Muss dann mit deinem Wissen in deinem Kopf irgendwie das wieder zurücktragen, das in diese Stelle einfügen und das kostet natürlich A Zeit B hat diese Geheimschutzstelle,
anscheinend sehr begrenzte Öffnungszeiten, das heißt mehr so öffentliche Bibliotheksmäßig oder noch schlimmer,
das ist einfach ein Unmengen an Arbeit, die die Leute irgendwie zu ihrer sonstigen täglichen Arbeit noch haben und da sind sie natürlich,
auf ihre Mitarbeiter angewiesen, deshalb sollte man, glaube ich, auch neben der Leistung von den,
Abgeordneten zum Teil vor allem von den Oppositionsabgeordneten auch die Mitarbeiter jetzt nicht unbedingt,
Vernachlässigen, die machen nämlich auch ganz viel davon und suchen und arbeiten und trackern sich dadurch diese Dokumentenberge durch.
Das heißt, sie sind dann auch nicht ganz unglücklich über euer Protokoll.
Na die bekommen ja eigentlich die offiziellen Protokolle. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wie schnell das geht, das heißt normalerweise ist es ja so,
die Protokolle dann nochmal den Zeugen gegeben werden und sagen die Zeugen, ob da irgendwas dran falsch ist oder ob sie irgendwas richtig stellen wollen und dann bekommen sie die, aber ich weiß gar nicht, was für Fristen das sind, das dürften so bestimmt zwei, drei Wochen sein, das heißt so
direkt sind die auch nicht da.
Das heißt bis dahin für die schnelle Recherche ist das wahrscheinlich auch eine Quelle. Vielleicht hören die ja sogar den Podcast.
Teilweise. Teilweise wissen wir, dass sie das tun.
Aha. Ja, es gibt ja dann.
Eigentlich nicht viel, also das normale Ritual, glaube ich, wenn ich's richtig sehe, besteht ja immer, äh es gibt halt die öffentliche Sitzung und dann gibt's.
Ilweise oder immer nochmal ein geheim Teil dazu oder manchmal eben auch nur geheim.
Teilweise gibt's den dazu. Das heißt irgendwie in der Sitzung sagen ja Zeugen öfter mal, das kann ich nur nicht öffentlich sagen,
und dann ist das quasi, dann schreiben die sich das auf ihren Zettel und sagen so okay, das könnten wir später noch fragen
dann kommt es zum einen darauf an, wie viel ist das, wie relevant scheint das jetzt das auch noch zu wissen, geht man wirklich davon aus, dass der da noch was zu sagen kann oder ob das nun eine Entschuldigung war, um jetzt irgendwelche unangenehmen Sachen nicht zu sagen
Oder hat man überhaupt noch Zeit dafür und dann kann es eben sein, dass die Zeugen noch in eine nicht öffentliche Sitzung gebieten werden,
die dann eben unter Ausschluss von Öffentlichkeit stattfindet, wo dann vorher auch die Handys und die ganzen elektronischen Geräte eingeschlossen werden müssen, irgendwann gab's mal die Angabe, dass dann im Hintergrund auch klassische Musik läuft, ganz leise, um die,
Pörung zu erschweren. Ich weiß aber ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob das stimmt.
Wurde uns mal so erzählt, ich habe es aber leider kann ich das ja nicht bestätigen. Ich finde aber die Vorstellung irgendwie extrem amüsant und das sind dann auch.
Wagner.
Genau und da läuft das dann alles nur noch mit Stift und Papier und ohne elektronische Geräte.
Ja das bringt uns ein bisschen zu den Erkenntnissen, also ist ja nun viel gelesen und geschrieben worden und jeder findet gerade wieder irgendetwas raus und so, aber natürlich,
gerade auch wenn man's versucht regelmäßig zu beobachten.
Aber natürlich noch schlimmer bei den Leuten, die es äh gar nicht so richtig beobachtet bekommen, aus welchen Gründen auch immer.
Was sind so was sind denn so die Erkenntnisse? Also was weiß man denn jetzt,
was man vorher nicht wusste, also Untersuchungsausschuss soll ja Dinge herausfinden und es gab ja einige Sachen, die ähm in diesem Untersuchungsausschuss das erste Mal äh auf den Tisch
kamen,
Manches war vielleicht äh im Prinzip auch schon bekannt, aber wurde so nie bestätig,
vieles bleibt sicherlich auch noch offen. Was ist so aus deiner Perspektive.
Rausgekommen. Was ist klar, was ist unklar.
Also am Anfang, als dieser Untersuchungsausschuss losging, sieht man ja vielleicht auch so ein bisschen an dem Titel, der heißt ja NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss.
Der Spionage der sogenannten Five Eis-Geheimdienste, sprich der Geheimdienste von Neuseeland, Australien, Kanada, Großbritannien und den USA in Deutschland beschäftigt und,
Ich glaube, man ist viel mehr davon ausgegangen zu untersuchen, was die denn Böses in Deutschland machen. Später hat man dann irgendwann gemerkt,
dass die deutschen Geheimnisse da viel mehr mit drinstecken, als man am Anfang dachte, das heißt, es war natürlich, war klar, da gibt's irgendwie Datenaustausch und natürlich gibt's da Kooperationen, unterlaufen Sachen, die nicht in Ordnung sind, aber ich glaube, das Ausmaß dessen,
und die Selbstverständlichkeit dessen war vielen einfach nicht bewusst. Wir haben zum Beispiel sehr früh.
Über diese Selektorenasphäre erfahren, was viele schockiert hat, was dann nicht mal primär erstmal über die Arbeit des Ausschusses rauskam, sondern über,
Recherche vom Spiegel, der dann irgendwann während einer Ausschusssitzung diesen Artikel veröffentlicht hat und damit erstmal in Ausschusslahmen gelegt hat, indem er eben gesagt hat, wir haben Dokumente, die zeigen, dass der BND,
der NSA hilft mittels Selektoren, also sowas ähnliches wie Suchbegriffe.
Ziele auszuspielen, deutsche Ziele auszuspielen, europäische Ziele auszu,
Politiker zu überwachen, internationale Organisationen zu überwachen. Das war glaube ich eine Sache.
Die viele schockiert hat in dem Ausmaß, dass man da Millionen von Selektoren hat,
Es bewegt sich jetzt nicht in einem, sage ich mal, kleinen Ausmaß, sondern.
Im wirklich im großen Stil dabei hilft, dann später kam irgendwann raus, was glaube ich auch sehr.
Schockierend war für viele, dass eben der BND das nicht nur für die NSA macht, sondern dass der BND auch in eigenem Interesse.
Rechtswidrige Selektoren,
sogenannten Auftragsprofil der Bundesregierung vorbei europäische Ziele ausspioniert hat wie zum Beispiel französische Minister und diese ganzen sogenannten Freunde, die man eigentlich hat?
Und das ist glaube ich eine Sache, die vorher nicht so glasklar offen lag. Da dachte man,
Vielleicht natürlich gibt's da Austausch, aber vielleicht läuft der nicht unbedingt massenhaft, sondern irgendwie mehr oder weniger anders bezogen mit Informationen angefordert werden.
'ne Sache, die auch durch den Ausschuss rauskam, ist auf,
sehr der Verfassungsschutz darin involviert ist, der Verfassungsschutz ist ja eigentlich,
Inlandsgeheimdienst, das heißt, der beschäftigt sich mit Sachen in Deutschland und,
Eigentlich darf der gar nicht so richtig mit äh der NSA reden und da gab's dann irgendwann dieses Hilfskonst,
dass man gesagt hat, na ja, man redet ja nicht direkt mit der NSE, sondern man macht das ja alles über den BND, der sitzt dann da dabei und dann sagt man, man hat so quasi das ist so ein bisschen über so ein Proxy gemacht, aber eigentlich macht das keinen Unterschied,
bekommt dann auch von der NSE kostenlos äh.
Bionage Software namentlich X Giescore, ein riesiges Spionageprogramm.
Eben im Gegenzug gegen Daten, zumindest ist das in den sogenannten Turms of Reference ist dem Vertrag, der damals zwischen,
Dem Verfassungsschutz und der NSA geschlossen wurde, so fest.
Genau das gerade vonstatten geht, wissen wir leider nicht und.
Eine andere Sache, die jetzt mal jenseits von dem, was wir an Fakten über diesen Ausschuss erfahren irgendwie.
Sehr aufschlussreich und schockierend ist, ist einfach die Art und Weise des Selbstverständnisses von diesen Geheimdienstmitarbeitern und eben zu sehen, wie da gearbeitet wird und,
sehr da viele Sachen egal sind und wie Leute da einfach sich.
Überhaupt nicht zu fragen scheinen, was für moralische Aspekte ihr Handeln hat, gerade wenn es auch um Datenweiterleitung, im sogenannten Drohnenkrieg geht, wo eben,
Vermutet wird das mit Daten, die vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und anderen weitergegeben wurden an die US.
An vielen Stellen überhaupt keine, sage ich mal, moralischen Zweifel daran zu bestehen scheinen, sondern man sagt sich, ja okay
uns hat keiner gesagt, dass man mit diesen Daten Menschen orten kann, wir gehen weiterhin davon aus, dass das nicht der Fall ist, uns hat das keiner bewiesen und eben gegen jegliche,
Lage quasi sich stur auf diese Position zu stellen. Na ja, weiß ich offiziell nicht, muss mich nicht interessieren, muss ich mir keine Gedanken zu machen.
Und das quasi nicht nur in den Diensten selber, sondern auch in Zeugen, die da zum Beispiel vom Bundesministerium der Verteidigung angehört,
vom auswärtigen Amt und diese ganzen Schichten, da sind dann die Aussagen, entweder haben wir nicht gewusst,
wir auch nicht nachgefragt, denn wir hatten ja überhaupt keinen Grund daran zu zweifeln, dass unsere amerikanischen,
irgendwas machen, was wir nicht wollen oder eben auch einfach war ich nicht für zuständig.
Also dieses war ich nicht für zuständig, ist einfach auch ein ziemlicher Klassiker, aber ist einfach auch was, was ein.
So irgendwie das Bedürfnis gibt mit dem Kopf gegen die Wand zu schlagen, wenn man da irgendwie Menschen hat und das Thema ist wirklich, dass da.
Menschen durch Drohnenangriffe getötet werden, der Amerikaner.
Eventuell eben mit Hilfe von Daten, die von Deutschland geliefert werden und dann werden dann halt die Zeugen gefragt, so na ja, aber.
Haben sie davon nicht in der Zeitung gelesen, weil da wurde ja auch viel drüber berichtet eben über Tontote und Prozesse, die es dann eben in dem Zusammenhang gab und sich dann irgendwie auf einen Standpunkt zu stellen, na ja, ich war da ja nicht für zuständig. Ich habe ja nur zufällig irgendwie
In der gleichen Behörde gearbeitet, in der Abteilung, die sich jetzt.
Vielleicht mit dem völkerrechtlichen Aspekt und irgendwie damit beschäftigt, aber dafür, nee, das war ja nicht meine Aufgabe, das,
mir keiner gesagt haben, mal kurz drüber nachzudenken und irgendwie diese Selbstverständlichkeiten, diese Ignoranz ist glaube ich auch.
Sehr, sehr beunruhigend, die man da gelernt hat.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass.
Dass diese Mitarbeiter, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das jetzt so genau sagen soll, aber mehr mh.
Sich mehr genötigt sehen äh in der Allianz mit ihrer Behörde zu gehen als mit der Idee des.
Wirken so, als wenn sie wirklich diese klassische, was sage ich mal, das, was man so als Beamtenklischee sieht, die dann einfach wirklich nicht drüber nachdenken und Arbeit machen,
Auf der anderen Seite gibt es eben.
Auch Leute, die ganz offen gesagt haben, so zu dem Thema möchte ich jetzt lieber nichts sagen, ich will ja auch in den nächsten Jahren noch für die Bundesrepubli,
Deutschland arbeiten, das heißt da so eine.
Einschüchterung.
Gewisse Einschüchterungen auch und einfach so, ich,
Ja, ich habe bestehe vielleicht nicht gerade irgendwie am Ende meiner Karriere, sondern irgen,
Anfang meiner Karriere und wenn ich jetzt dazu irgendwas sage, dann geht die vielleicht nicht so gut weiter und.
Da es einfach viel auch,
was an Vertuschung passiert, wo man sich halt auch fragen muss, wer deckt jetzt eigentlich wen und da wurde auch oftmals irgendwie so, das hatte man so das Gefühl, gerade wenn,
Zwischen verschiedenen Zeugen über Verantwortlichkeiten für ein Thema geredet wurde, zum Beispiel über
Affäre, dass da so ein bisschen die Verantwortung vom einen zum anderen geschoben wurde und der eine dann eben sagt, naja, das hat aber der dann gemacht, aber
dann war der für zuständig und ich hab das ja dann gemeldet und dann war das ja quasi für mich erledigt, dass da einfach so dieses
solange verschoben wird und niemand kann es wirklich beweisen, weil auch zufällig dann Sachen gelöscht wurden und Dokumentationen gelösch,
wurde und dann Dokumente nicht mehr da sind, dass dann eben solange der.
Der schwarze Peter rumgeschoben wird, bis man nicht mehr weiß, wo er am Ende landen soll.
Das heißt.
Unterm Strich ist der Untersuchungsausschuss schon.
Hilfreich, man gewinnt Erkenntnisse, hast du das Gefühl, dass man genug Erkenntnisse.
Genug Erkenntnisse haben wir natürlich nie
Also wir müssen's halt auch klar machen, eine Menge von den Sachen, die ans Licht gekommen sind, sind erstmal auch nur mit Hilfe von Medienberichten ans Licht gekommen. Das heißt, nicht mal durch den Ausschuss selbst, der hatte ja teilweise, dem wurden ja auch Unterlagen vorenthalten. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es eben,
auch diverse Abgeordnete gerade in der Unionsfraktion, die halt auch nicht so viel Interesse an Aufklärung haben, aber halt leider,
Redezeit haben und natürlich hat man
nie genug Informationen unter Aufklärung durch diesen Ausschuss, nichtsdesto,
ist natürlich dieser Ausschuss,
relativ einzigartig, das heißt irgendwie so eine Aufarbeitung wie eben in Deutschland gab's jetzt in keinem anderen Land, das es gibt, obwohl natürlich auch noch viele andere Länder von dieser ganzen NSA-Affäre sozusagen betroffen waren. Das heißt, das ist glaube ich.
Gut, dass es diesen Ausschuss gibt, eben, weil sich dann auch damit parlamentarisch beschäftigt wird und weil auch dieses Thema einfach sehr, sehr lange,
immer wieder in der Berichterstattung oder in der Öffentlichkeit landet, wo natürlich auch die Aufmerksamkeit ein bisschen abnimmt, aber nichtsdestotrotz ist das einfach eine wesentlich ausführlichere Beschäftigung, als man sie sonst hat.
Aber man muss auch die Grenzen von diesem Ausschuss sehen, das heißt, es gibt einfach Dinge, dieser Ausschuss nicht untersuchen können würden,
und gerade wenn es darum geht, was die Geheimdienste der Five Eis machen, da hat man einfach keine Handhabe, weil einfach,
Man nicht die Möglichkeit hat, zum Beispiel Leute von britischen Geheimdiensten oder von,
US-Geheimnisen vorzuladen. Dieses Recht hat man einfach nicht. Man kann zu den BND,
gehen und sagen, ihr müsst uns jetzt diese und jene Person schicken, dann müssen die das machen, dann kann,
die Person vielleicht irgendwie ganz oft sagen, sie kann sich an nichts erinnern, aber zumindest muss sie da auftreten, aber man hat eben diese Handhabe
außerhalb von Deutschland hat man eben nicht und da gibt's eben auch noch ganz viele Sachen die im,
borgenen Liegen und die man mit diesem Ausschuss nicht aufklären kann, weil man einfach auch nicht die rechtlichen Mittel dazu hat.
Extern, dass so dieses Konzept Untersuchungsausschuss an sich ähm das richtige Mittel wäre, wenn man ihnen nur ein wenig ähm reformiert,
oder bedürfte es. Was bedürfte es sozusagen noch oder alternativ dazu äh zusätzlich.
Auch sowas so die Rolle der Medien betrifft, die da im Prinzip grade schon eher positiv,
Magazine, die relativ früh,
auf das Thema eingestiegen sind, andere Zeitungen haben sich teilweise auch hervorgetan. So in der Summe,
würdest du meinen, wie ist die Beobachtung der Erkenntnis gewinnen und die,
auf dem Untersuchungsausschuss liegende Schlussfolgerungen am Ende, wie hat das funktioniert.
Glaube, das ist eigentlich relativ positiv. Also es haben viele,
Zeitungen oder viele Medien, sage ich mal, immer wieder berichtet, irgendwie gerade Zeit und Zeit online haben da immer wieder viel zu gemacht und kalbiermann war immer wieder im Ausschuss, Deutschlandfunk hat viel dazu gemacht und es war einfach immer, immer, immer, immer, immer, immer wieder Thema.
Natürlich gerade, wenn jetzt irgendwie über lange Strecken Zeugen kommen, die jetzt nicht prominent sind und eben auch nicht öffentlich bekannt sind
die vielleicht aber an der Ebene arbeiten, wo wirklich was passiert, sprich nicht nur diese Art politischen Zeugen sind, die am Ende für alles sich irgendwie verantwortlich zeichnen müssen oder überall ihre Unterschrift runtersetzen, sondern,
auch mal die Techniker vom BND oder vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, die interessieren vielleicht diese großen Medien nicht und da gibt's natürlich auch.
Im Gegensatz zu sage ich mal dem, was wir bei Netzpolitik auch machen, einfach wesentlich mehr Redaktions,
wenn dann eben gesagt wird, darüber berichten wir nicht und dafür haben wir jetzt keine Ressourcen, weil wir jetzt lieber.
Irgendwie jemanden,
zu einem Thema schicken, das jetzt vielleicht Öffentlichkeitswirksamer ist oder wo sich irgendwie vielleicht mehr Leute für interessieren und nicht nur so dieser harte Kern, dann geht das natürlich unter. Dann ist das nicht schön und deshalb versuchen wir das halt auch im Nachhinein zu dokumentieren,
wir müssen uns halt auch klar machen, dass dieser Ausschuss.
Für Konsequenzen für den weiteren Verlauf von,
Heimdienstgesetzgebung und Geheimdienstkontrolle in Deutschland passiert, wie,
daraus wirklich konkrete Konsequenzen für den BND für das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz und andere Erwachsenen und das sieht eben momentan nicht so besonders gut aus. Also man hat zum,
einen natürlich die persönlichen Verantwortlichkeiten von Leuten die da arbeiten und Fehler begangen haben, wo auch klar ist, dass da wirklich,
auch von Personen als Einzelperson ohne Zweifel Fehler gemacht wurden und da gab es schon früh die Aussage.
Von der BND Spitze, das ist keine Dienstrech,
Konsequenzen geben wird für irgendwas, was Leute da im Ausschuss erzählen.
Das ist natürlich ein Problem, weil Leute jetzt erstmal,
ja einfach komplett ohne Konsequenzen dahin gehen, vielleicht werden sie dann noch in ihrer Abteilung versetzt. Wir haben irgendwann gab's Berichte, dass drei Menschen im BND eben ihren Posten wechseln, aber das ist dann natürlich auch eine, sage ich mal, mehr oder weniger symbolische Geschichte. Aber,
Was wir eigentlich bräuchten, wären wirklich eine Einschränkung dieser Geheimdienstbefugnisse.
Was wir da gesehen haben, was da passiert und wie unkontrolliert das passiert und eine bessere Kontrolle dieser ganzen
zusammenarbeiten, auch mit Geheimdiensten von anderen Ländern, aber da sieht es halt gerade nicht so gut aus.
Mhm. Wollt ihr ja nicht hinten anstellen, aber vielleicht äh an dieser Stelle schon mal.
Ganz interessant.
Steht durch die Bundesregierung, weil man bisher auf alles reagieren und überhaupt und so und so kann es ja nicht weitergehen.
Jetzt zeichnet sich aber so ein bisschen ab. Na ja anstatt dass man sagt ach.
Wie die haben jetzt was Illegales gemacht, jetzt müssen wir hierfür mal äh die Befugnisse äh so klar ziehen, dass das nicht mehr passiert,
eher so ein bisschen gerade den Eindruck, als ob
Die Initiative jetzt so bisschen so läuft, wie man das zuletzt auch in England beobachtet hat. Großbritannien, nach dem Motto acht Jahren was illegales gemacht und dann müssen wir das Gesetz jetzt mal so erweitern, dass das gar nicht mehr illegal ist.
Das heißt, wir erleben jetzt eigentlich das, was,
glaube ich auch nicht neues, also was auch schon nach früheren Geheimdienst äh Untersuchungsausschüssen und nach großen Skandalen äh passiert ist, dass am Ende eigentlich die Geheimdienste mit mehr Geld dastehen und,
auch mit mehr Befugnissen oder weniger Einschränkungen zumindest.
Genau, die Befürchtung hatten wir ja schon länger, das heißt, äh, so der erste Punkt,
so diese Befürchtung richtig aufkam war, ist die sogenannte Weltraumtheorie ans Licht kam, das heißt
Die kann man vielleicht auch nochmal ganz kurz erklären, weil ich finde, das ist eine der Perlen dieses Untersuchungsausschusses, die zu Tage kamen.
Da hatte man irgendwann das Problem, dass man in Bad Aibling.
Mittels, also Satellitenkommunikation abgefangen hat und in ganz, ganz großem Stil ausgewertet und an die NSA weitergeleitet hat und.
Das kann man laut dem Gesetz schon machen, dann muss man das aber genau dokumentieren. Das hei,
und.
Anscheinend um so ein bisschen so 'ne öffentliche Diskussion aus dem Weg zu gehen und sich irgendwie für seine Dokumentation oder eben auch nicht Dokumentation oder unzureichende Dokumentation und Kontrolle des Ganzen irgendwie zu rechtfertigen hatte BND sich dann.
Mit dem Segen des Kanzleramtes die sogenannte Weltraumtheorie ausgedacht, der hat nämlich gesagt, dass was wir in Bad Aibling machen, nämlich irgendwelche Satelliten abhören,
Das passiert nicht in Deutschland, weil die Satelliten, die sind ja nicht in Deutsch,
sind wir im Weltraum und deshalb gelten da keine deutschen Gesetze. Und,
Das war so eine Theorie, wo man dann dachte so, das kann doch nicht sein. Da muss sich doch jeder vernünftige Menschen.
Fassen und da muss man doch jetzt irgendwie gesetzlich regeln, dass das eben nicht geht und dass man sich nicht so 'n Hahnebüchen und Mist ausdenken kann,
Und da wurden dann schon von einigen Seiten aus der GroKo klar, dass eigentlich diese Praxis nicht abgeschafft werden soll, sondern dass man die einfach auf.
Rechtliche Beine stellen soll, das spricht eben sie zu legalisieren und das haben wir jetzt bei ganz vielen anderen Sachen eben durch den ersten Entwurf.
Oder nicht den ersten Entwurf, sondern durch einen Entwurf zur BND-Reform,
Nur dafür gilt, sondern dass in vielen Teilen eben das, was der BND gerade so an Überwachungen macht, gerade in der sogenannten Auslandsauslandsüberwachung, sprich von Kommunikation, vom Ausland in ein anderes Ausland.
Massive Erfugnisbeweiterung passieren und irgendwie vieles von dem, was sie heute tun,
Plötzlich vollkommen legalisiert wird und auch einfach noch viel mehr Befugnisse gegeben werden und diese ganzen schwammigen,
Begriffe, mit denen man jetzt schon ein Problem hat, einfach noch schwammiger werden und man so ein,
Generalzugriff. Nun bekommt den wollte man eigentlich schon zweitausendacht haben.
Haben man die noch nicht gekriegt, mittlerweile ist es dann soweit.
Heißt zum Beispiel das ist irgendwie 'ne Obergrenze.
Von Übertragungskapazität, die abgehört werden darf an bestimmten Knoten, dass die noch diskutiert wird, aber die war sowieso noch nie wirksam, dass man es jetzt nicht mehr nur noch hat, dass man einzelne Leitungen oder.
Einzelne Verbindungen komplett überwachen darf, sondern man soll dann auch komplette Kommikationsnetze komplett überwachen dürfen. Das heißt,
Man hat dann nicht mehr nur das Problem, dass der BND,
viel Auslandsauslandskommunikation drüber geht, von sogenannten.
Krisengebieten, wie man gerne sagt, sondern man hat dann eben das Problem, dass man einfach sagt, naja, wir hören jetzt einfach die ganze,
Telekom ab oder wir nehmen einfach die Glasfaser, den Glasfaserverkehr der ganzen Telekom mit. Und das ist einfach.
'ne Sache, die das Ausmaß von Überwachung, die passieren darf, massiv steigern wird, was wahrscheinlich heute schon passiert, aber das wird dann eben einfach noch ein bisschen.
Na gut, ich.
Die deutschen Telekommunikationsnetze als Krisengebiet zu bezeichnen wäre ja jetzt auch äh kein Fehler, von daher ist das ja durchaus eine legitime Argumentation.
Na ja, aber eigentlich eigentlich will man ja immer, ne? Man sagt ja immer, wenn wir das abhören in Deutschland, zum Beispiel, in Frankfurt, an Internet knoten,
interessieren uns ja eigentlich die ganzen innerdeutschen Kommunikation, die interessieren uns ja nicht und wir wir wollen ja an Leitungen gehen, wo wir jetzt zum Beispiel wissen, da läuft.
Vielleicht Kommunikation von weiß ich nicht,
Afghanistan, nach Pakistan oder von irgendwie einem europäischen Land in ein Krisengebie,
immer irgendwie geflüssentlich ignoriert. Und was eben auch,
massiv aufgeweicht wird, ist eben sind so die Gründe, für die man an diese Glasfasern oder an die Kommunikationsnetze gehen darf. Man sagt jetzt neben.
Eben sowas wie na ja, wir wollen das jetzt nicht nur zur Abwehr von Terror, was man ja öffentlich immer so gerne sagt, um die bösen Terroristen abzuwehren, sondern
Wir dürfen jetzt irgendwie deutsche Provider abhören, um die Handlungsfähigkeit der Bundesrepublik Deutschland zu wahren und was man irgendwie unter diesem Begriff irgendwie fassen kann, kann man sich ungefähr vor,
nämlich wahrscheinlich im Endeffekt so ziemlich alles oder wir wollen
sonst tägliche Erkenntnisse von außen und sicherheitspolitischer Bedeutung gewinnen und das ist einfach
da merkt man einfach, sollten die Alarmglocken losgehen und sagen, dass irgendwie sonstige Erkenntnisse von irgendeiner Außen- und sicherheitspolitischen Bedeutung auch so ziemlich alles sein können.
Gut, das ist jetzt ein Entwurf, der wurde euch irgendwie jetzt euch in die Hände gefallen.
Er ist irgendwo vom Laster gefallen.
Wie äh solche Entwürfe das ja äh gemeinen tun, sprich
der ist noch nicht äh im eigentlichen Sinne äh publik gemacht worden, aber das ist sozusagen wohin die Reise gerade zu gehen scheint, ist irgendwie lässt sich irgendwie äh ab ähm lässt sich lässt sich irgendwie absehen.
Wer da wessen Handschrift das trägt.
Und da hat man sicherlich erstmal ganz viel Handschrift von Union.
Und SPD auch drin, wobei wir erstmal, glaube ich, davon ausgehen, dass es irgendwie ja sehr, sehr viel Unionshandschrift regt, aber wer genau da jetzt so seine Hände drin hat und wer nicht,
natürlich erstmal nicht so richtig sagen, da gibt's auch noch einige strittige Punkte drin. Wir wissen ja auch zum Beispiel.
Dass es in der Union große Fraktionen gibt, die sich auch vorher immer schon wieder dafür ausgesprochen hat, den BND nicht zu entmannen, zum Beispiel,
Gewisser Herr Meier von der CSU, der eigentlich auch im Ausschuss sitzt, aber da irgendwie von mir zuminde,
nie gesehen wurde, aber der ganz oft sich eben dafür stark gemacht hat, dass man den BND doch bitte nicht zu viele Kompetenzen entziehen solle,
eben dann schon so ein bisschen, dass da bestimmt einige Personen am Werk waren.
Entmannen. Die Formulierung heute benutzt.
Genau, er hat gesagt, wir dürfen den BND nicht entmannen, weil sonst kommen alle bösen Terroristen und wir sind komplett schutzlos und ähm dann können wir überhaupt nichts mehr aufklären.
Weil die böse letzpolitische Szene in einem Schniedelwurz gezopfelt hat.
Zum Beispiel, weil da würden die dann eben nicht mehr alles darf, was er will.
Oh je.
Genau, aber wir müssen auch nochmal schauen, nämlich der Entwurf, den wir veröffentlicht haben, da waren noch einige Stellen drin, die noch,
In Abstimmung waren zum Beispiel wie viel Prozent der Kommunikation abgehol,
werden dürfen oder ob es so eine Begrenzung überhaupt geben darf und noch so einzelne Worte, das heißt, es wurde ja auch letzte Woche berichtet.
Dass man sich auf einen Entwurf geeinigt habe und eben diese Entfassung des Entwurfs.
Wurde eben noch nicht öffentlich gemacht und da müssen wir mal warten, was der Bundestag dann im Endeffekt vorgelegt bekommt und wie der Bundestag dann auch mit diesem Entwurf umgeht und was daran noch passiert oder passieren kann.
Und wir müssen natürlich auch sehen, dass es jetzt erstmal einen Entwurf zur Reform von einem BND-Gesetz. Aber wir haben ja noch ganz viele andere Gesetze, die irgendwie Einfluss auf unsere Geheimdienste haben. Wir haben zum Beispiel.
Das Gesetz über das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium und über,
und prüfen soll und da sind einfach noch viele andere Aspekte von Geheimdienstkontrolle, jenseits jetzt dessen, was der BND konkret an Befugnissen hat, die noch eine Rolle spielen werden und bei denen es,
sicherlich auch noch Reformen geben muss und wo auch schon teilweise von Fraktionen entwürfe oder sogenannte Eckpunkte für,
vorgestellt wurden, die mal mehr und mal weniger weitgehend und wo man einfach nur mal schauen muss, was da am Ende bei rauskommt und eigentlich.
Es ist ja auch so, wir haben ja diesen Ausschuss und der Ausschuss hat ja eigentlich auch das Ziel, dass da am Ende.
Vorschläge für Rausfallen, wie man das besser regeln kann, aber der Ausschuss ist ja noch gar nicht fertig, das heißt, der Ausschuss geht erstmal.
Aber der muss natürlich vorher aufhören, Leute zu befragen, weil er einen sogenannten Abschlussbericht anfertigen muss.
Das ist noch nicht ganz klar, wann das passiert, wahrscheinlich so im nächsten Frühjahr wird dann irgendwann angefangen mit diese,
Bericht wirklich in eine heiße Phase zu gehen und da werden ja ideal weil idealerweise auch Vorschläge zur Geheimdienstreform drinstehen. Wenn natürlich bis dahin schon.
Sage ich mal Tatsachen geschaffen wurden, weil eben nach Plänen von Leuten aus der Regierung diese,
zumindest BND-Gesetzentwurf oder Reformentwurf bis zum Ende des Jahres verabschiedet sein soll,
Gibt's da auch so eine gewisse Diskrepanz dazwischen, dass man erstmal überhaupt gar nicht wartet, darauf was macht denn dieser Ausschuss noch
Es wirkt mehr so ein bisschen so, als wir drücken das mal schnell durch, bevor da noch irgendwas rauskommt, was uns das vielleicht so ein bisschen vermiesen könnte oder wo dann die Öffentlichkeit dann so ein bisschen äh wieder schlechter Stimmung sein könnte.
Ja, dann kann man ja auch dafür sorgen, dass sozusagen zur nächsten Bundestagswahl im Prinzip alles auch legal ist, was äh der Geheimdienst. Äh so macht es da wirklich sehr praktisch.
Hat man quasi keine Skandale mehr, da hat man die quasi nachhaltig.
Ja genau, weil ist ja jetzt alles erlaubt.
Ist ja alles erlaubt. Wir haben das jetzt einfach nur nochmal, das war ja alles vorher auch schon erlaubt. Wir haben es einfach nur nochmal klar geregelt, damit da keine Missverständnisse.
Genau.
Jetzt wissen die, woran sie sind und jetzt können sie das machen und brauchen kein schlechtes.
Das ist auch besser für die Bürger.
Immer. Also wenn die Geheimdienste gut arbeiten können, ist das immer auch besser für die Bürger, weil dann werden die nämlich besser geschützt.
Mit der Freiheit und der Sicherheit und dem ganzen und so und Sicherheit ist ein super Grundrecht und das ist alles ganz wichtig.
Ja, was ist denn das Restprogramm des äh NSA-Untersuchungsausschusses? Jetzt gab's ja noch die äh das,
Da hat ja die Opposition gedroht, dass wenn äh das nicht
getan wird, dann würden sie halt einen neuen Untersuchungsausschuss äh einklagen wollen, was auf Basis der äh rechtlichen Situation wohl äh die Täter abgelehnt werden können und das äh hat wohl als Drohung,
ordentlich gezogen und jetzt gab es diese Erweiterung des Auftrages.
Genau, das diese Drohung muss man so ein bisschen sagen.
Eigentlich will das niemand noch einen Untersuchungsausschuss, wir haben irgendwie in dieser Legislaturperiode jetzt schon fünf und das ist irgendwie so viel wie seit den sechzigern nicht mehr. Also das ist.
Fünf Stück, was wir haben den neuen wenn das.
Gibt's einen zu den sogenannten Cum-Ex-Geschäften, das ist irgendwas mit Finanzen und jetzt gibt's noch einen zu diesem Diesel-Gate, das heißt irgendwie da gab's einfach eine ganze Menge
Und das ist natürlich auch eine massive Arbeitsbelastung. Das heißt, für jeden von diesen Ausschüssen,
geht quasi ein Tag komplett drauf für die entsprechenden Abgeordneten und ihre Mitarbeiter und auch für die Leute, die dann von der Bundesregierung da dabei sitzen müssen, das heiß.
Also ein Tag pro alle zwei Wochen oder.
Sitzungswoche, das sind so ungefähr alle zwei Wochen. Und das Ganze muss natürlich noch vorbereitet werden. Dann,
den will eigentlich niemand haben, weil ich meine, es kommt ja nicht plötzlich mehr Geld dadurch irgendwie, dass mehr Ausschüsse da sind. Das heißt, eigentlich war das für niemanden so das Mittel, das man haben wollte. Das war natürlich eine,
Drohung und ein Druckmittel, das im Zweifelsfall durch.
Diese Erweiterung vom Untersuchungsauftrag, da muss man sich überlegen, wo die herkommt, warum man die eigentlich haben wollte. Und zwar kamen die daher, dass man natürlich am Anfang,
vieles noch nicht wusste und natürlich wenn man Dinge nicht weiß, kann man ja auch nicht sagen, dass man die untersuchen will. Und.
Wenn man dann eine Bundesregierung in der hinteren Reihe sitzen haben will.
Hat, die dann bei allem, was eben nicht.
Zweifelsfrei und ein eindeutig in diesem Auftrag drinsteht, sagt, das ist nicht Untersuchungsgegenstand, darüber dürft ihr nicht reden.
Sogenannten BND-Selektoren. Das heißt nicht den Selektoren,
die die NSA dem BND übergeben hat, um Dinge zu überwachen, sondern die, die sich der BND dann selber gesucht hat und die äh von der NSA übernommen hat und mit denen er dann im eigenen Interesse,
rechtswidrige Aufklärung gemacht hat zum Teil und eben zum Beispiel europäische Ziele abgehört hat und da wollte eben die.
Aber unter Verwendung von X Giescore, also schon mit dem.
Generell.
Irgendwie auf ihren eigenen System wie auch immer. Also erstmal nur quasi was der BND so für lustige Suchbegriffe benutzt hat,
Und da wollte die Opposition einfach ganz viel zu fragen, uns wurde immer wieder gesagt, nee, da dürft ihr nicht, da dürfen wir überhaupt nicht rangehen, das dürft ihr nicht anfassen, das ist BND-Eigenes, Dings und ihr seid ja im Endeffekt nur der NSA-Untersuchungsausschuss, hat hier damit nichts zu tun.
Das war irgendwann Ende letzten Jahres schon klar, dass man da irgendwie noch ein riesiges Thema hat, wo man gerade nicht rankommt und dann.
Wurde dann glaube ich im Februar von der Opposition so dieser Antrag.
Stellt eben diesen Untersuchungsauftrag zu erweitern und da gab's eine massive Blockadehaltung von der großen Koalition.
Sagt so, nee, das wollen wir eigentlich nicht und dann erstmal versucht, hat das,
verhindern. Und zwar erstmal auf bürokratischem Weg. Das heißt, man hat,
diversen Sitzungen vom Geschäftsordnungsausschuss des Bundestages diskutiert, das heißt, man hat erstmal irgendwie ewig lange drüber diskutiert, wie und wann und wo und wer überhaupt jetzt darüber diskutieren soll
wie man sich darauf einigen sollte, diese ganzen Sitzungen vom Geschäftsordnungsausschuss waren nicht öffentlich, das heißt, wir wissen nicht genau, was da passiert ist und was da besprochen wurde.
Es gab dann wirklich nur die Befürchtung, dass das so lange rausgezögert wird, bis es überhaupt keinen Sinn mehr ergibt, das überhaupt zu behandeln, weil man eh keine Zeit mehr dafür hat. Das war so die Befürchtung, die alle eigentlich hatten.
Dann kam es irgendwann dazu, dass ähm der.
Und der Herr Fritsche, das heißt, der Chef vom Bundeskanzleramt und der ähm Beauftragte für die Nachrichtendienste,
In diesem Ausschuss kamen und da erzählt haben, wenn ihr jetzt.
Untersuchungsauftrag erweitert, dann ist das eine Gefahr für die innere Sicherheit Deutschlands,
und das Ganze ist aus zwei Aspekten richtig, richtig fragwürdig, nämlich aus dem einen Aspekt, dass plötzlich die Regierung,
ins Parlament kommt und dem Parlament erzählt, was es denn zu tun hat, weil eigentlich haben wir sowas wie Gewaltenteilung und das auch aus gutem Grund und da so eine Beeinflussung vorzunehmen, ist erstmal nicht so ganz die feine Art und auch überhaupt nicht üblich. Und auf der anderen Seite natürlich so.
Gefährdung der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, dadurch, dass man ein paar Fragen stellt, wo dann die Fragen, die interessant sind, eh meistens nur im nicht öffentlichen Teil geklärt werden würden, ist halt auch schon mal eine irgendwie.
Aussage, mit der man irgendwie, an der man zweifeln darf und wo man sich fragen darf, so was wollen die jetzt eigentlich verhindern an Aufklärung und warum wollen sie das denn verhindern? Und dann kam es dann relativ überraschend, anscheinend dazu, dass man sich letzte Woche im Geschäftsordnungsausschuss geeinigt hat.
Und zwar hat man sich darauf geeinigt, den Untersuchungsauftrag zu erweitern, aber,
ursprünglichen Antrag der Opposition wurden einige Punkte rausgenommen. Zum Beispiel.
Dass man die BND-Selektoren untersuchen darf, die abgelehnt wurden oder vom BND in irgendeinem Punkt quasi aussortiert wurden, inaktiviert wurden oder gelöscht wurden,
aber eben nicht die Gesamtheit der BND-Selektoren untersuchen darf, was natürlich das Problem mit sich bringt, dass man,
Nur das zu sehen bekommt, von dem der BND selber sagt, ist nicht in Ordnung, man kann sich jetzt aber kein Bild davon machen,
Was von den wahrscheinlich Millionen von noch vorhandenen Selektoren die aktiv sind eben auch nicht in Ordnung ist. Das heißt man kann irgendwie nicht einschätzen wie viel läuft denn da gerade noch was genau so mies ist im Endeffekt, sondern man sieht erstmal nur, dass wo der BND selber gesagt hat geht nicht mehr.
Nichtsdestotrotz ist das nicht komplett sinnlos, da es natürlich,
irgendwie diverse Fragen, sage ich mal, so rund um den Prozess dieser Aussortierung gab. Wir wissen zum Beispiel, dass,
auszusortieren oder als nicht in Ordnung zu markieren als eben diese ganzen Slowen Geschichten schon angefangen haben,
Obwohl eben schon mal zweitausendfünf, zweitausendsechs so diese
berühmten Selektoren zu ihr, die ersten Eurocopter aufgefallen waren. Das hat man aber anscheinend jetzt nicht zum Anlass genommen, mal generell zu gucken, sind da noch andere Sachen
drin und einen ähnlichen Prozess erwartet man halt auch für die BND-Selektoren, weiß man noch nicht und das wird man jetzt zumindest mal fragen dürfen.
Die waren noch gar nicht da, so ihre Kollegen, wie der Herr de Maizire und so, die waren schon mal da. Angela Merkel war noch nicht da, was,
jetzt ganz gut ist gerade, da der Auftrag erweitert wurde und man sie dazu dann auch einfach gleich mitfragen kann,
heißt, wir werden davon ausgehen, dass unsere Bundeskanzlerin oder.
Noch Bundeskanzlerin auch mal geladen wird. Es wird wahrscheinlich auch noch andere interessante Zeugen geben, Zeuge auf den ich mich freue und von dem ich sehr hoffe, dass er noch kommt. Ist der Joschka Fischer.
War ja na ja so ein bisschen aus der Geschichte raus bisher hatte man ja primär so Zeugen aus sag ich mal dem,
verantwortlichen politischen Bereich irgendwie von so Union.
So weiter eben und aus der Regierung eben, aber der Herr Fischer, der war ja damals zurzeit als Nine Eleven war.
Geheimdienstkooperation zwischen Deutschland und den USA so richtig Fahrt aufgenommen hat, das heißt weil so die Anfangszeit,
als Schröder,
und hat sich auch, sage ich mal, im Nachgang mehrfach dazu geäußert, auch in Interviews und Ähnlichem, dass hier Deutschland diese Kooperation mit den USA unbedingt bräuchte und dass die auch,
das heißt Fischer ist zumindest in den Äußerungen, die bereits von ihm bekannt sind,
relativ positiv gegenüber dieser Geheimdienstkooperation eingestellt und hat da sicherlich auch maßgeblich Dinge mitbekommen und mitdiskutiert.
Und ist natürlich ein Grüner, was natürlich so ein bisschen vielleicht mal so die Frageintensität umkehren könnte, weil natürlich.
Dann auch die Union und die,
die vielleicht ein Interesse daran haben, mal wirklich böse Fragen zu stellen, um mal zu gucken, was passiert und.
Leider bei SPD werde ich mir dann in dem Moment nicht so sicher, wenn wir von einer rot-grünen,
Zeit reden, aber das stimmt schon,
Union wird da sicherlich nochmal äh eine andere Intensität und mindestens eine andere Personalanwesenheit am Start haben, ne? Damit würde ich ja schon mal äh sicher rechnen.
Also ich glaube zumindest mal so diese diese Verhältnisse von die Opposition darf immer nur nachbohren und hatte erstmal nicht viel zu befürchten, dass über sie selber was rauskommen könnte und dann sitzt dann plötzlich ein Grüner. Ist vielleicht nochmal eine ganz interessante, sage ich mal, soziale Frage.
Ja, das wäre auf jeden Fall ein Medienhighlight, das ist natürlich klar.
Ich hoffe, das passiert. Also es ist noch nicht ganz klar. Ich meine, es gibt natürlich noch ganz viele andere Zeugen, die man laden könnte. Es werden jetzt auch nochmal ganz viele Zeugen wahrscheinlich neu geladen
diese Erweiterung des Untersuchungsauftrags, die man halt
früher nicht fragen durfte zu diesem Thema, die jetzt einfach nochmal kommen werden und da muss man immer schauen.
Ja, Anna. Ich glaube jetzt.
Und es ganz schön umrissen. Ich fand das ein super äh super Rundumschlag so, um mal so ein bisschen zu verstehen. Muss man vielleicht versuchen ein bisschen zusammenzufegen.
Ist eine Menge Arbeit. Nochmal Untersuchungsausschüsse verträgt sie Legislaturperiode wahrscheinlich äh nicht mehr, allein schon personell, äh nicht nur was äh,
die äh hauptamtlichen Teilnehmer daran betrifft als auch irgendwie eure Rolle. Wie viele wie viele Sitzungen stehen jetzt noch auf.
Was noch nicht ganz klar, weil noch nicht ganz klar ist, wann begonnen wird diesen Abschlus,
zu schreiben. Also ich schätze mal.
Vielleicht,
sage ich mal so zwanzig öffentliche Sitzungen, grob geschätzt, so überschlagen, aber es kann natürlich auch sein, dass jetzt noch Sondersitzungen einberufen werden, wenn man jetzt eben diesen,
Auftrag erweitert hat und merkt, dass man nicht mehr hinkommt. Das heißt,
dieses einmal in der Sitzungswoche Sitzung ist erstmal so die Regel, aber es kann natürlich auch immer vorkommen, wenn man merkt, da sind grad Themen, die man behandeln muss, dass dann noch Spontansitzungen.
Meinetwegen Mittwoch oder Freitag noch dazugerufen werden.
Zehn bis zwanzig.
Ich denke mal, aber das ist jetzt auch wirklich nur so eine grob übern Daumenpeilung.
Das muss noch festgelegt werden, das steht auch noch nicht fest.
Ja, hast du noch ein noch ein letztes Wort? Ein Wunsch.
Mein mein Wunsch ist immer, kommt mal vorbei, das mit dem Vorbeikommen ist auch ganz einfach, da schreibt man einfach anders Sekretariat eine E-Mail mit seinem Namen, Geburtsdatum, Geburtsort glaube ich und dann kann man da einfach.
Sekretariat.
Anlass Sekretariat des Untersuchungsausschusses. Da kann man aber auch bei der technischen Aufklärung, bei dem Podcast,
Das kann man bis zum Vortag der Sitzung mittags um dreizehn Uhr machen, das heißt da muss man sich auch nicht Ewigkeiten vorher anmelden,
manchmal bei prominenten Zeugen ist dann halt schon voll, wenn man sich ganz kurz vorher anmeldet, aber in der Regel geht das echt unkompliziert und da braucht man nicht mehr als dann hingehen und seinen Pass mitbringen und sich da reinsetzen,
und das lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Gibt's da einen Kalender eigentlich, den man sich mal äh abonnieren könnte.
Die technische Aufklärung hat auf der Seite auch einen Kalender mit den nächsten Sitzungsterminen. Ansonsten.
Kann man sich auch oft in Seiten des Bundestages den Sitzungskalender einfach erstmal raussuchen und,
also in pink markiert ist als Sitzungswoche am Donnerstag ist in der Regel eine Aufschusssi.
Kalender. Sehr schön. Das wollte ich schon immer mal haben.
Ja, die gibt's auch so in in ganz klein und Checkkartengröße, damit man sich immer daran erinnern kann, wann gerade Bundestagssitzung ist.
Chico. Ha, abonniert.
Das ist immer.
Muss man sich erstmal Experten so einladen. Kommt auf jeden Fall mit äh in die Shownotes. Weitere Wünsche hast du erstmal nicht.
Ich wünsche mir, dass alles gut wird, dass die Geheimdienste nicht mehr so viel dürfen, vielleicht irgendwann, dass es keine mehr gibt, aber das sind erstmal Wünsche, die nicht in den nächsten zwei Jahren erfüllt werden, glaube ich.
Könnte schwierig werden, ja. Aber kannst ja trotzdem schon mal auf die Wunschliste setzen, weil.
Bis dahin Jobsecurity, ne? Also.
Ja. Ja, siehst du mal, du bist auch abhängig davon,
am Ende würdest du's nicht verhindern, dass es verhindert wird,
Wo soll ich denn da sonst noch Protokoll schreiben.
Ja genau. Genau, ihr seid ja äh da sehr empfänglich und äh wer sozusagen Einblicke und Einsichten äh hat in
digitaler Form, da ist dann Netzpolitik Ork auf jeden Fall ein guter Ort, das umzusetzen und es wird auch bekannt dafür, dass die Quellen auch geschützt bleiben.
Wir geben unser Bestes.
Ja, wir haben jetzt auch unser Bestes gegeben. Anaiser, vielen Dank.
Ich sage auch danke. Viele Grüße an Linus. Wo auch immer er steckt,
nichts falsches tun?
Komm wieder heim, komm wieder zu uns und so.
Ja und äh wir gucken mal, welche Belege wir noch finden können. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war unser kleines Spezial hier, Logbuchnetzpolitik nächste Woche geht's wieder weiter. Bis bald.